foreign
ly was not sick this past week I lost my
voice if you noticed if for those of you
that listen to the culture War podcast
on Friday there was a point where I was
like all that coughing something up like
my just lost my voice and then I was
kind of like sick Sunday and then I'm
like yeah I'll be fine tomorrow and then
I woke up on Monday being like I can't
talk and then Tuesday I was like I still
can't talk and then by Wednesday I was
like okay we got to get somebody to host
the show because like one or two days
out I thought it'd be fine but so a
special thank you to Jack besobic and
Seamus Coughlin for hosting the show in
my absence I have returned we are here
to talk about news and as we're
preparing for the show huge news is
breaking we don't know if that's any we
don't know what's true and what's not
there's a lot of propaganda you got to
be careful but the reports that are
coming out is that there is a potential
military coup or Civil War starting in
Russia I'm Gonna Stand Megan Bay I I am
skeptical of this but apparently the the
private military contract of the Wagner
group apparently is saying that they're
going to stop the corruption in Russia
and then Russia is deploying troops to
try and gain control of things we I
don't know how much of this tree we're
going to talk about all of that plus a
lot of other big issues I think we've
got to talk about this cage match with
Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg because
you know I've been out all week I do
want to address the uh the the debate
that Joe Rogan uh offered up and the
money I know this is It's a weak old
story but I haven't been here all week
so explaining my position on why I
offered the hundred thousand dollars to
add to this and to refute a lot of the
points that were made by some of these
people that are clearly lying and just
absolutely address look
they say don't have debates we had a
show with Emma vigiland and uh Sean
actual Justice Warrior who's here with
us today right now actually on the show
and I thought it was it was fantastic I
thought we should we absolutely do want
to have more of these debates
conversations whatever you want to call
them so the fact that there are people
saying not to do it is a problem and
we're gonna we'll address that but we'll
talk about a bunch of stuff before we do
my friends of course head over to
castbrew.com and purchase cast Brew
Coffee we got a bunch of awesome flavors
you can join the cast Brew Coffee Club
you'll get three bags per month and you
can also buy the rise with Roberto Jr
which I think is our most popular uh
blend it is a light roast and with every
purchase you get a picture of Roberto Jr
our rooster he does a good job of taking
care of his chicken ladies out in
chicken City so uh support our work the
purpose of castbrew is it is our brand
as we're launching the coffee shop this
it is currently under construction and I
gotta tell you for those of you who know
construction you know exactly what's
going on I'm sure I can hear Trump he
knows exactly what it's all about the
moment you start building they're like
in two months you'll be done and then
they knock down a wall or something and
they're like oh look what we found and
now you got to go to permitting that's
another month and they're like after we
did this we discovered this and we
discovered this and so now it's like
okay we're going to redo the building we
should just be done with it so we're
jammed up on that but in the meantime we
are selling cast brew coffee so uh
please consider supporting us we sponsor
ourselves because we don't want to rely
on companies that could pull their
sponsorship and we want to build a
parallel economy also don't forget you
can download the timcast Android mobile
app by going to timcast.com and clicking
mobile app it's available for Android
right now both apps are done but we need
Apple and Google to approve of us to put
us in the app store for the time being
you can download Android don't forget to
also become a member to support our work
I've been gone all week so um I want to
say this
a special thank you to every single one
of our members before we were doing any
kind of membership website I could not
take six time off because all of the
revenue generated was predicated upon
whether or not I uploaded a video but I
just want you all to know how much it
means to me because you guys are members
at timcast.com I know that if I can't
physically work because I lost my voice
or I'm sick or something that the people
who are working on the infrastructure
and behind the scenes at timcast.com
don't have to worry about not getting a
paycheck we don't have to worry about
the company going out of business
because you guys are members you allow
us the opportunity to sometimes get sick
so I really really do appreciate it
joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more is the wonderful Benny
Johnson what up how we doing
we out here we are I've been reading the
comment section yes it is me up in the
comments section with my pimcast beanie
this is a 50 cal
this is inside of the thumbnail
uh but it is reveal
a reveal a pen
it is a pen I have uh I have another one
here this is from a from a company
called accidentally awesome and I saw
these on their uh stand there in West
Virginia at Charlestown and I'm like oh
50 BMG what's that I grabbed it I'm like
this has got to be something and that's
a pen it's wonderful
so there you go cheers yeah uh we got
Sean hanging out hi I'm back I live here
now actually yeah yeah after the early
morning appearance Tim is like I guess
you you're here so just stay here so
yeah I was like when are you leaving
it's like I'm not I'm like oh come on
the show there you go all right we got
Brett hanging out what is going on guys
it's Brett I am the host of Pop Culture
crisis Monday through Friday you should
go check out today's episode but let's
talk uh let's talk politics let's do it
before we get started I just want to
thank you Tim for taking the week off
it's a strange Bittersweet thing it was
an example of how this company can
function and flourish without Tim having
to be on the floor every day the amount
of people you know that are cool the
amount of employees you've hired that
are cool that can take the reins and
move this thing along whether you're
here or not it is I think when you look
at companies like the Blaze the where
Glenn Beck started it but now he's able
to just have a show and have a huge
awesome company of interviewers and and
shows like that's the direction it was
wonderful to be a part of thank you
what's happening Serge uh yeah it was
good but I'm glad that you're back to
him it's uh gonna be easy to keep on the
rails than with uh Sheamus running
everything
and everybody saw it happen yes it was
live on air so anyways glad you're back
man let's go all right so here's the
first story from the Daily Mail cool
fears as Wagner Army Marches On Moscow
to Target evil military Chiefs Kremlin
accuses a leader of mercenary leader of
mercenaries leader of mercenaries of
inciting Civil War puts its troops on
Capitol streets and vows to smash armed
Mutiny as State tv runs emergency
Bulletin
this is crazy they say there are fears
of a coup in Russia as military vehicles
were seen in the streets after the chief
of the is it Wagner group or is it
Wagner group Wagner I think that's
that's actually appropriate
pronunciation they called for an armed
rebellion and direct challenge to the
Kremlin yevgeny Prego gen tonight
pregosian said his Force had crossed
into Russia as he called for the ousting
of Russia's defense minister and vowed
to punish military leaders whom he
accused of killing 2 000 of his Fighters
the Wagner Chief said we had cross-state
borders will destroy anything that gets
in the way we go all the way we got this
photo at sear photo here armed vehicle
armored vehicles were allegedly on the
streets of Moscow so the first thing I
had to say is um was that saying but
believe half of what you uh what is it
believe half of what you see and none of
what you read or hear or whatever I know
something like that take it all the
grain of salt I don't know for sure but
I will say this when I first heard this
story I was like what did NATO offer him
double
like this is how it goes with pmcs he's
fighting in Ukraine they're getting
demolished and then he's like it's not
worth the money he's a he's a private
military contractor what does he care
and then NATO says what are they paying
you dude and he was like you know 50
million he's like okay we'll give you
200 and he was like okay sure that's all
it takes right money printing machine
goes Burr this is the danger of hiring
versus mercenaries to fight a war uh
happened to the Rome I don't know if
this is exactly what happened with the
Romans but they were having they were
bringing in Mercenaries from all over
the world to come and fight for the
Romans because the Roman citizens it got
to a point where they didn't want to
fight anymore and then uh that's the
beginning of the end because those
people do not have any allegiance to
your country this is the American
Revolution they brought in the British
brought in German mercenary Hessians
yeah
those are the people who got routed by
uh when ju when when when when George
Washington I almost said Joe Biden my
God uh when George Washington crossed
the Delaware it was the Hessians who got
routed Christmas Eve yeah that the
famous painting right the most famous
painting of the Revolutionary War that's
who he was going to fight the Germans
actually yeah I mean there is obviously
value to having a um a more robust
fighting force including mercenaries but
if you're relying on Mercenaries you're
in a you're in a very precarious
position this is what I never understood
you see a movie where it's like someone
hires a hit man I'm like and they always
say like what are they paying you I'll
pay you double it's just like why would
why would not this doesn't be like well
okay sure are they going to turn me in
if I if I don't do this I don't think
they're going to you have a reputation
to protect you as a Hitman though but
this is something that we see there's a
great book called The Modern mercenary
and there's a phenomenon that they call
neo-medievalism because one of the
problems during the Middle Ages was that
people had an allegiance to their lord
their God and their King so whenever
there was like a you know a conflict
broke out that was between any of them
you had to pick your own uh you had to
pick which Master you would serve so you
know mercenaries have different
interests different loyalties and all
that so obviously we might be saying if
this is true that Neo medieval order
like establishing itself once again in
our modern society so they're you know
they're they they obviously aren't loyal
to Russia no he he's he says uh quote
there are 25 000 of us and we are going
to figure out why chaos is happening in
the country promising to tackle any
checkpoints he said he I asked that no
one offer resistance is 25
000 really enough to do anything I I
mean if they're centralized just in
Moscow yes
like they could take some building or
something but I just want to point out
that we're no longer in the era of being
able to take over a country by occupying
a building and it's kind of crazy to
think that was the case at some point
like a bunch of dudes would run into a
building and they were like we're in
charge now and everyone will be like
well crap they're in charge now yeah I
worked in uh Pinochet did that I think
with uh what was I ended cellular
Allende in Chile there was 11's in the
70s I think it's like they just went in
but once you get the leader that's what
he wants is he wants the defense
minister if this is real he doesn't care
about the building but you can get the
people if you get Putin then you get
Putin at gunpoint to tell the people I
concede I stepped down you know you get
the leader to do what you want them to
do I think well power is influence right
so symbols of power do matter so
occupying Moscow even though
strategically you're like you're right
like they could move to another city uh
you know the Russian government has
access to nuclear warheads you would
think this doesn't matter but
symbolically occupying Moscow is a huge
deal and if people believe that this
mercenary group has more powerful than
the defense minister guess what it's
more powerful than the defense minister
has anybody ever occupied Moscow
since the beginning since the Kiev the
the old kievan princes yeah
right every Empire died trying but like
has anyone have a group right like it
like this is it the US finally figured
something out there like hold on hold on
we can't invade let's pay someone else
to do it there you go oh the French
occupied Moscow we didn't just figure
that out I think America's been doing
that for us Moscow has been occupied six
times in its history by Foreign armies
wow the Polish in 1610 uh
France when was France French occupation
1812 Napoleon made it to Moscow I didn't
know I didn't realize that I thought it
was crazy Napoleon the summit of the
French but then what did he tried he
tried going further he lost his army
they only occupied it for 36 Days the
city was devastated by fire this is all
from Wikipedia
um and I'm just kind of oh yeah it
wasn't like they destroyed everything
the Russians they're pulling could have
any supplies and then he got screwed
over in the winter and was like we're
dying Scorch Earth policy as you Retreat
you burn everything so that the enemy
doesn't have anything is that scorched
Earth I thought was when you destroy
everything so that they cannot raise a
defense like you destroy farmland and
kill civilians you can be right because
Sherman's March to the Sea I think was
the first modern example of scorched
Earth whereas he marched South he'd
start destroying farms and killing
civilians and just wiping them all out
you could be right the Romans did it to
Carthage there is a tactic where as
you're being occupied you destroy
everything didn't they do that with
Richmond the South they they sacked
Richmond to prevent the union from being
able to utilize it or something like
that I don't know that is common it's a
very common and when you're desperate
you to burn your uh your defenses as you
as you Retreat so that the enemy's not
able to occupy I mean they're doing that
in Ukraine who do you think blew up that
giant damn the Nova Dam but it wasn't
the Russians well this is the funny
thing like nordstream for instance
they're like Russia blew up its own
Pipeline and you're like
nah bro
like nah that's no Ukraine blew up the
dam is is this this is not definitive
though this is like you've got warring
propaganda so the New York Times uh did
a report on how Ukraine has sort of
poison pills all throughout the country
to blow up their own infrastructure in
the Washington Post said that they did a
test strike on the dam uh earlier in the
year like they did an operation to test
so you can just connect the dots there
yeah and I think the blowing of the dam
flooded or has potential to flood Crimea
the Crimean that's right it really hurts
the Russians to blow up the dam and it's
a very bad thing who benefits from this
so the pipeline that was destroyed is
the one that allows them to transport
oil in gas without going through Ukraine
so obviously that gives them the ability
to cut off the ukrainians from energy so
that would be a prime target for the
ukrainians to destroy or their allies
being the United States or whoever
like it wouldn't make sense for Russia
to cut off their own strategy
this is a it's a good kind and they're
and they're sorry they're winning too
aren't they that's also it's tough to
tell but here's what I noticed they've
been saying uh Western forces Western
media has been saying Russia has been
losing the whole time and then I keep
looking at these maps of territory and
Russia's expanding its control over the
Don bass and I'm like I'm confused like
now they're saying that this region
where the dam is is controlled by Russia
and I'm like wow Russia controls how
much I thought they were losing that
they were getting pushed back I thought
that was this big offensive that pushed
back into Russia but Russia controls all
this land I was like but it doesn't
sound like they're losing I mean I'm not
here to say they're winning or anything
but it doesn't sound like they're losing
dude I don't know though I don't know
there's a lot of propaganda this will be
if this truly is that the Russians
accidentally shelled 2 000 of their own
mercenaries and now the mercenaries turn
on them that will be remembered for
tens of thousands of years if we have
history for that if we can maintain it
it'll be remembered as one of the
largest military blunders ever in the
history of humankind I just don't
believe it yeah it's it's a it's a
convenient piece of propaganda exactly
and it's it's much simpler that
a multi-billionaire went to the Wagner
group and said we will give you 100
billion dollars to your company you will
be the preeminent in in the you know
Eastern Hemisphere military contractor
for all of our work forever you will
want for nothing side with us
it's a simple question you go to the guy
and you say do you think Russia's going
to win and he's going to be like
is it really worth how much money he's
paying you well this is what we do it's
like we'll pay you 10 times as much and
you'll win and he goes deal that simple
we did just have a what 6.2 billion
dollar accounting error
no joke maybe yeah whoops and now the
guys got six billion dollars he's
probably alive dude he made he makes a
video claiming whatever he wants how
much money they have to give him to make
it happen probably not a lot he's a
private military contractor he runs a
business if he he works with Russia and
Russia ends up succeeding or pushing in
this fight
his only custom his only customer is
going to be Russia he's looking right
now they're probably telling him listen
once this whole thing dies down you've
got potential conflict in the country a
country B country C country D you've got
China Taiwan you've got you know uh the
entire continent of Africa and South
America we can hire you for all of these
things but if you operate with Russia
that's the only customer you will ever
have yes and and what are you gonna buy
after they may have even gone said after
we we flatten Russia where will you live
will you with with all of the great
money they paid you will you buy a
building in Siberia perhaps or how about
this we give you a billion dollars you
turn out of Russia and you can buy
property anywhere in the world
heck we'll give you an island
not a hard deal that's the danger of
using mercenaries there's an island
called little Saint James that is
recently unoccupied and it has a special
temple on it that's brand nearly brand
new lightly used special blue and white
temple those are your colors right
Wagner blue and white you'll love this
place
it's got a real Eastern European Flair
to it yeah this is the pro I mean yeah I
didn't think you might I mean obviously
I think you might be right here I'm
furiously searching for the map the
wartime map because actually Russia's
gained a enormous amount of territory of
Ukraine's and this Ukrainian offensive
that they've been talking about has done
nothing it's actually been an absolute
total failure you don't hear about it
because we're propagandized as much as
anyone else in the world but the the the
Ukrainian spring offensive has been
there it has been very very bad and as
you can see where all the money is gone
it's now in flaming tanks and uh
personal carriers all throughout the
Eastern front of Ukraine and the most
effective group if you go through on the
YouTube and some of the YouTube channels
and you're able to do the Google
translate thing and you're able to
listen to these Ukrainian generals talk
the people they're actually scared about
is the Wagner group that's that's the
people they talk about they say the
Russian army is is ineffective it's this
Wagner group these guys are actual
operators they are sophisticated they're
smart and they're all they also have a
wartime experience so they're not
rattled at all because Russia's putting
a lot of young guys on the front lines
and so if you go through and you watch
some of these YouTube some the key of
post is the one that I watch right
because they do they have these Insight
in these interviews with these these
Ukrainian generals and they talk about
how uh worried they are about the Wagner
group and how a skilled of an operation
that is
and so this is clearly something that is
if they if you were to take them off the
board off the chessboard uh well hot
damn I mean this would be a big thing
obviously for Ukraine I always thought
about mercenaries and what a what a a
hard life that is because the the people
that hire you to fight want you to die
on the battle that they win they want
you to win the battle but die so they
don't have to pay you so it's like they
don't have Russia doesn't care about
these people like the Russians they want
to win and they would rather not pay
them to be honest uh obviously they
liked loyalty over non-loyalty but
mercenaries know that and if you kill
their men man they they are not gonna
wait we don't do very well with taking
care of the people who fight our our
Wars either though so it's not like
that's uh I mean I see what you're
saying but in general I don't really
think that uh in most cases many of the
people that come back from war are
really taken care of in any way shape or
form so but veterans make up 11 of all
the homeless population in America
veterans make up 11 large portion of the
suicide our veterans yeah we do use
mercenaries in part because the soldier
death number is what always gets
reported because the American people
care about soldiers dying overseas and
when it's Personnel even though they're
former soldiers that served our country
that went into these mercenary groups
it's not as like scary of a number so
like there is some more concern in the
United States for at least the death
toll especially overseas and we started
like upping our use of private military
after we started withdrawing troops at a
certain point right back in like 2013 or
something like that in Afghanistan yeah
so just just to clarify because people
are pointing out scorched Earth two two
super chats saying that it's when people
are def when a defending Army destroys
everything another person responded it's
actually both uh but most most famously
associated with offending armies
destroying anything of use to the place
they're occupying but there are several
circumstances in which people in their
own countries destroyed everything as
they were fleeing but scorched Earth
uh the specific examples when you pull
up the Sherman's March to the Seas like
the most notable modern example yeah and
that was when he was like destroy the
Farms destroy the railroads anything
they can use the the purpose was to
destroy their will to fight so just to
completely demoralize I thought about
the Third Reich did this in Russia like
when they they were on the edge of
Moscow as far as the Third Reich got in
Russia and they were as close as any
modern Army's been to to conquering
Moscow and man they burned the they they
burned everything on their way back but
we we gotta we gotta talk about a more
important fight that maybe on our hands
ladies and gentlemen and it's not
Ukraine and Russia it is Elon Musk and
Mark Zuckerberg vox.com reporting why in
the world are Elon and Zuck planning to
punch each other their supposed cage
match has Petty online Roots
um all fours as the boys are fighting
okay I love this they are 51 and 39
years old respectively and we got to
inform you that they're gearing up for a
cage fight in an unconfirmed location
but possibly Las Vegas on a 2B decided
date Elon Musk signaled his interest in
the match on Twitter a few days ago
Zuckerberg naturally confirmed that he
was he was in through Instagram uh so
what's the latest on this this is this
is going to happen or the latest is Dana
White uh came out and acknowledged this
is real they said they're very serious
about it they want to do it it's the
coolest thing Zuckerberg has ever done
they're saying the weight classes like
the the different weight classes will
make it difficult for them I think this
is why they should go to Mars they
should have this fight on yeah
that's it's like um but the other thing
is like uh elon's mom was saying she
doesn't want him to do it I put a poll
up on our chat today I asked people I
said you know who do you think would win
and I think they're wrong I think people
are saying musk is going to win and I
think if you've seen the videos of of
Zuckerberg doing his doing Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu he looks like a robot when he's
doing it his face is completely blank I
think I think he ends up winning this
one so
it if I just want to say this first the
first question is will this actually
happen and I lean towards it won't I
hope it does can you imagine that the
insurance policy you'd have to have to
run this fight
there's a 37 second video this is a good
point why it won't happen because every
investor every every investor in
Facebook and every ancestor investor in
Tesla will file an injunction
immediately and be like
if one of you gets knocked out we're
gonna lose billions of dollars you know
that's a good point because Dana said
Dana White the owner of the UFC said
that it would raise a hundred million
dollars in pay-per-view and it'd be the
biggest most popular fight of all time
yep um but you're right I had trauma to
Elon Musk could end Tesla and then
they're just like you make one bad
decision and you're bored votes you out
there like we saw you get hit in the
head by Zuckerberg like you we can't
trust you to make decisions musk is 51.
yeah and Zuckerberg's a trained I mean I
don't know how trained but a trained
Jujitsu fighter all right so let's let's
talk about this though Zuckerberg does
Jiu Jitsu he does there's that video
that went viral where he claimed the ref
claim that he tapped out but he didn't
and Zucker got all got all mad about it
uh Elon Musk is just a guy however Elon
Musk is also much much much larger than
Zuckerberg Zuckerberg's actually a
little dude also five eight or something
do they get to five seven 154 150 what's
what's musk uh six one six two and uh
195 which I think is kind of
conservative for his way he looks pretty
big there's no no way he's what that's
what he's listed as minimum so what yeah
I think he's smart
I think it's a minimum oh his height is
six one six two right for that height
alone with his build he's looking at 2
10 to 20. so my executive producer just
went to Twitter and met with Elon Alx
he's been on the show everyone knows hey
awesome great dude follow him on Twitter
blue pass 500 000 and also by the way
Benny Brigade thank you for one million
Subs this week we just crossed that uh
Milestone on Wednesday so God bless you
thank you Alx has been my executive
producer for five years met with Elon
Musk and he's like yo I'm 5'2 Alex is
I'm sorry six two at a Lex is every bit
of a tall dude all right neon Moss was
taller than him wow Elon Muslim bait it
was a big guy hey Alex tweeted he's like
yeah Elon Musk way bigger than I thought
he'd be in person have you seen the
photos of him on the on the boat with
Bezos he's a he's a big dude he's a big
big dude also the the other thing for it
for for musk is like I just don't know
if like can they find the time to do
something like this is there really time
to to get something like this done uh
when you're running five companies I
think so because they're both robots you
know and they know that time is relative
so when you create a piece of art that
goes on the internet that is seen 100
million times it creates like when you
think of time you're creating 100
billion minutes as opposed to spending
maybe 7 000 minutes to get it done you
you've actually made more time more
importantly if than if they can find the
time to do this is is Elon going to make
the time to train because Zuckerberg and
he's younger than him and you know he is
fighting right now and he's training
with the best he's a billionaire like he
can afford anybody so can Elon but Elon
Andrew Tate says I'll train you Jorge uh
Jorge Mazda doll says I'll train you
Elon Musk there's been a bunch of MMA
fighters that are like yeah I will train
you Sam Hyde Sam Hyde huh he's the guy
no I think I think Andrew Tate if he
goes to Romania and trains with Andrew
Tate that would be hardcore because even
that would be awesome to watch we live
in such a weird world where it's like
you just kind of accepted this dude who
might or might not be a human trafficker
is gonna train the guy who runs five of
the biggest companies in the world to
fight another dude who's worth more than
some small country's GDP and you're just
like whatever like like back in the day
this would have happened on Celebrity
Death Match no more
take the cartridge out blow on it put it
back in let's go reset the game you just
accept that like is this dude who's
maybe guilty of unspeakable crimes
really possibly going to train this dude
who's now got people mad at him because
he won't let them say sis on Twitter
it's it's a weird world we live in you
think it's a good idea for them to fight
I I mean yeah because I think I'm I'm
all for the hilarity of it all I think I
think it's hilarious but like I mean if
I was an investor in either these
companies I don't know if I want the guy
especially musk who's like the
brainchild of those companies Facebook
is kind of its own thing now right right
face like I think Facebook does find if
if Zuckerberg isn't around anymore musk
is very much a forward-facing Persona
that is the face of those companies you
can't have that dude coming out here
looking like Reagan in the second
Administration and like looking like he
doesn't know what he's talking about
right like he has to be coherent he has
to know what he's talking about he has
to look like he's on this game all the
time two two things one um do you well
first of Elon Musk smoked with Joe Rogan
and Tesla stock plunged immediately so
this would have an impact if he got
knocked great time to buy something to
be worried about and number two
um do you guys are you guys a little bit
worried that Bezos is getting into shape
Zuckerberg is doing MMA like they know
something we don't know like no they did
not something most people don't know and
it's you got to eat right take care of
yourself that's just it that's right do
you think they're preparing for
something where they might have to do
engage in Mortal physical combat like
it's societal collapse no no no I mean
those Bezos is in shape because he's got
his new wife he's gonna take his other
half of his mind I think if you take a
look around you'll notice a few things
people are drinking a lot less I mean
I've noticed we've noticed that
anecdotally because we do this great boo
selection and people come in and we hear
this all the time oh I stopped drinking
recently we also know that Millennials
drink a ridiculously lower amounts of
soda than past Generations yeah it's the
first time in American history that so
does not like the number one drink in
America I mean I hate us we have these
uh these liquid deaths where the total
sugar count is 6 grams I've actually in
this whole can I've gone to kombucha uh
it's not expensive you get a lot of it
it's it's like a sweet tea fermented no
sugar it says yes I think they sweeten
it with an alcohol but this is my point
when it comes to all of these guys we
see them they're very visible but the
reality is the trend and getting
healthier is just across the board well
you should the wealthy do eat better
than us the covet it was covet freaked
me out I I'm fully focused on physical
yeah tell that to Bill Gates though Bill
Gates Ian has a filet mignon every day
every day a a nice wagyu beef yes raw
raw he's just kidding it's good to have
your Heroes and the people that you look
up to in society be masculine men if
you're a man it's good to have
testosterone flowing through your veins
Mr Beast tweeted recently that he's
getting in shape and that he he called
himself obese and that he's been
training every single day and eating
right and uh stopping drinking and I
think this is a wonderful example the
set for young men actually you shouldn't
want to be a slob filled with
microplastics and unable to defend
yourself or support your family in my
case physically support my family
because I need to pick my little kids up
and down you know or walk up the stairs
right to literally be a father you have
to be a masculine man you have to have
energy if if not a cage match for the
issue of the stock and potential
lawsuits and injunctions they need to do
some kind of like manually sporting
competition arm wrestling
I'm wrestling baby they're not gonna get
hurt they're not going to get hurt arm
wrestling at least not not severely
like the helmet thing but maybe wear
like helmets right or something
Americans
they do that with the giant toothpicks
very musk to me like there's a meme
there's meme potential in that that I
think that's a good one maybe we do like
uh like five events it's like arm
wrestling it's the giant Q-tip thing
where they you know Bop each other with
them and maybe maybe a soccer bopper on
a bridge where it's like the log what
about the big big airbags so I do want
to say this as somebody who was raised
in Iowa that don't count out Zuck
because he's shorter or smaller we've
been having this like size comparison
elon's big man like dude these short
guys growing up in Iowa the reason I say
that is because wrestling country
everyone's a wrestler yep and these
little guys these little guys who've
wrestled featherweight like one one uh
120 right 120 or 110. they're little
dudes and they have those cauliflower
ears they will kick your ass those guys
will cause you more pain it's actually
little guys at the bar with cauliflower
ears you got to stay away from well
those guys will hurt you uh
I don't know if I'm supposed to tell the
story so I'll just keep it very vague
but someone we know who's a fighter said
that he was at a bar once and some guy
was mouthing off and he was like just
leave me alone dude and then his
brother's like dude dude stop and
pointed to his ears oh yeah he said that
on the show I was watching that show
yeah that was awesome yeah and it's just
like I'm I'm pretty sure like you see
that you're like it's not that they're a
good fighter it's that they are a
fighter and you are not don't don't go
in that race also when you're little you
always feel like you have something to
prove never piss off a short cop ever in
your entire life so what's the worst
thing in your tablet because they're
quick to anger and they're always going
to be trying to prove themselves just
don't do it so if this fight if this
fight comes to term I prophesy
Zuckerberg goes for there's gonna be
some weak weak strikes Zuckerberg goes
for the legs wraps them up really fast
puts him in some pain that he wasn't
expecting and musk is out that's my then
the undercard can be all of the people
that work for their companies like their
vice president's fight and I I love it I
love it you know it would be even better
though if they're
if they're in the middle of their fight
all of a sudden there's like
a a sound or a horn trumpet and then
they look up in the rafters and there's
Jack Dorsey and then he like ropes down
yes like Shawn Michaels yeah exactly
that's right and then you start hearing
this like glitchy house music and Elon
Musk calls in a Tesla bot that and comes
and takes his place TAPS in it's like an
ai ai versus Zuck and then Zuck rips his
human exoskeleton off his face and he's
like lizard people they fight right AI
versus the Lizard people they finally
have the battle we've all been waiting
for somebody could just make this movie
now we don't need this to actually
happen Joe Rogan's calling it right Joe
Rogan's there hold on hold on can we
just can we just go back to reality for
one second Joe Rogan will be calling
them calling the fight how insane so
when we saw that story where it was uh
Trump's in the audience with like was
like Kid Rock and like who else was
there Mike Tyson Mike Tyson and I'm just
like what what's this Dana White
Donald Trump Donald Trump Kid Rock Mike
Tyson and Joe Rogan's in there calling
the I'm like this is the weirdest we
live in a simulation they just tell me
I'm sorry that's just it Rogan we got to
give some credit to Joe Rogan this guy
people love him obviously but like he
brought people together humans together
across so many strata of reality like it
is so awesome to watch doctors hang out
with Fighters sorry Penny were you about
to say something I'm just everyone's
saying that uh Donald Trump needs to be
the ref oh that'll be hot get him a nice
pin white stripe black and white striped
shirt I I have so much love for Rogan
not only just because of what he's doing
with the show but the fact that the
grand macro scheme of what he's how he's
been able to bring people together I
think I'd rather have Trump do
announcement with Rogan oh yeah I think
he would be better off in the announce
Booth like it's the color commentator
yeah that would be amazing it's against
tremendous
Trump would be biased against Zuckerberg
right yeah in the fight that's funnier
it's funnier if he has like clear face
favorites that he's picking oh he's like
he's gonna run all his grievances
against both of them he's like this guy
begged me for support during us
now he's gonna submit so the real
question we'd ask is like how do we make
something like this actually happen even
if it was WWE style where it's all fake
and silly and over the top would be the
best thing ever that was my pitch it's
like they should just have WWE do it
because you could actually write story
lines for these people and it would be
really really funny to watch the The
Writers come up with something
absolutely ridiculous
Bezos like shows up and then it's like
Battle Royale and they're all just in
the rain Bezos comes in and helps
Zuckerberg and then Dorsey comes in and
helps Elon Elon because he's like yeah
you're my Twitter brother in arms he
bought you bought it for me and they
become the Twitter Tag Team bro like
let's do this this is this is the per it
is a simulation right Jack Dorsey is
wearing Twitter 1.0 and elon's running
22.0 shirt suddenly like the lights go
out in the entire Arena and you hear I
don't know some type of Latin music from
the Amazon and in comes an Amazon drone
with an Amazon box and in the box of
Jeff Bezos
he bursts out of it right he comes in an
Amazon truck they back up an Amazon
and a guy's got a a dolly with a box
that he carts into the into the into the
cage and they're like What's this then
he puts it down and then outside it just
bursts open and there's precedent for
this because Stone Cold Steve Austin and
he's like I'm in my pry Stone Cold Steve
Austin once drove a a beer truck to the
ring and jumped on Vince McMahon we can
have Bezos drive an Amazon truck to the
ring and just jump on top of both of
them this is perfect let's do this I
want to see like them bust like Elon
pick up Zuck and like smash him through
the ground and as he falls down lands on
like the next scene which is they're
fighting out a Starship and then we make
that happen The Babylon B had a meme
today that said like Zuckerberg and Elon
saw their differences by playing
GoldenEye 64 only slapping each other in
in two-player mode but you got to play
on a license to kill mode where one hit
kills if yeah and then you're like oh
like this back and forth like that yeah
one of them takes blofeld because he's
smaller so they can't actually slap him
oh sorry yeah what did you say uh
blowfeld who's that that's another
character oh really no odd job is the
short one yeah and we always had the no
odd job rule yeah yeah yeah Jaws sucked
too he threw his hat yeah people the
best who would be the one person that
like unites them all right because
that's the thing you need if you're
writing the WWE script somebody has to
show up that unite then they have to
forejoin forces right like the Power
Rangers
Communist party like anyone's opposed to
the the oligarchs you know what I mean
like you have to be like Logan Paul but
Xi Jinping would be the best heel Xi
Jinping would be amazing evil the like
the bad owner he'd love it too that's
right the sweatshops in the background
we always did the like the evil
Foreigner stereotype and all of them the
Iron Sheik just passed away so Jesus
ping would have to take over for that
she doesn't have to say anything he's
just kind of stand there and like chill
and smile a little bit and you're like
do I trust him or not I don't know put
him in a Winnie the Pooh outfit yeah
let's just we're gonna completely jump
off the cliff on this story and just
move on to politics we have this one
from Fox News Kareem Jean-Pierre spars
with reporters refuses to answer Hunter
Biden questions in testy exchanges
although it's interesting because the
way it was described to me is that the
the Press Corps has completely turned in
the Biden Administration I mean Ian and
Benny were both like it was bad dude we
should watch part at least part of the
four minute video of the reporters one
after the other picking up where the
other one left off creamy like I'm not
answering that question you what do you
want and they're like well I just want
to continue with their question she's
like I'm not answering it okay you and
he's like I want to continue with the
the old reporters quick it was stunning
but you were saying Benny that they're
like they're done with them and this is
they're getting pushed out because the
there's the hunter Biden story and then
there was more importantly the uh the
Ocean Ocean Gate Scandal where
apparently the government knew for a
week that this sub had likely imploded
and they didn't tell anybody the this is
the this is our federal government's
version of uh 66. Joe Biden's getting
Order 66 right now if you see it
you'll never be able to unsee it follow
some of the New York Times writers
follow some of the Washington Post
writers follow Chuck Todd we have to do
it professionally I would never
recommend you do these things because
you'll never get anything useful what
you'll see is the order has gone out you
are now allowed to attack
you are now allowed to ask your question
why does Chuck Todd after three years
Chuck Todd finally finds this story
interesting and he leads NBC Nightly
News with a seven minute episode on this
CNN's report at the White House was the
one who's the most Savage in this video
that we're gonna watch hopefully uh to
Korean Pierre oh yeah CNN New York Times
NBC News they're all ganging up on Biden
nah man or 6610 let's play this clip
here we go
oh it's not working what's going on
I'm wondering if you could take us into
the thinking and the decision making of
why you're not asking this question I'm
just not going to get into family
discussion personal family discussion as
you know Hunter is a son I'm just not
going to get into this if Hunter Biden
wasn't the president's son would he have
invited someone who had just reached a
plea agreement with Federal prosecutors
a couple of things again that's his son
it's a he's a family member it is not
uncommon for family members to attend
events at the White House you could look
at past presidents I'm sure you have so
that is let's jump ahead so here's the
thing and I appreciate United States
Who's involved as this message seems to
suggest in some sort of a coercive
conversation for business dealing by
assignment is that something so this is
referring to this text that went out
where what Hunter was basically like I'm
sitting here with the big guy right now
and we'll put all our Force against him
let you do it he says I'm sitting here
with my father and he says it twice in
the text multiple times yeah uh it's a
WhatsApp text and it has not been
refuted this text seems legitimate so is
Moyer responded to the text today
confirming Hunter Biden's lawyer
responded to the text confirming that it
was a legitimate text that the text is
real to the Communist Chinese
apparatchik wow and what was the defense
oh my client was on drugs at the time
sitting next time
so uh this morning we did the first of
our uh new so so the idea for the
culture War show was always to be like
having the debates that we sometimes
have on IRL but don't fit the format we
do topical news here having someone on
who's going to debate turns into a
debate show so Friday morning will be we
had on Emma vigiland and one of the
conversations we had was me saying I
don't quite understand why there are so
many people on the left who don't like
Joe Biden but will absolutely defend him
on these scandals instead of just saying
sure
and for some reason we got into the
argument and this uh this individual she
was very much like I don't think it's
real the barisma stuff's not true you
know there's no evidence to prove it
shokin was not investigating I'm like I
just he was like I don't understand but
now I'm wondering if if they're going to
change tune these uh these these Lefty
types now that we're seeing the signal
flare has gone up it is now open season
to to go after Joe Biden on the on the
corruption Scandal I think so this is I
was like this is one of the most
jaw-dropping pieces of news media I've
ever seen in my life I mean it is it is
incred anyone that cares or has been
following the hunter Biden scandal the
stuff with barisma anyone over the last
three to four years watch this video
watch it from start to finish You're
Gonna Want More when it ends I don't
know if they they only got three and a
half out of her but I mean this is a
tactic that can be continued to you be
used by the news media until forbid they
were supposed to
it's right they're supposed to ask about
these stories but it's but this is the
point I was bringing up in the in the in
the debate show I'm like how about if
you don't know whether or not Joe Biden
did or did not engage in a quid pro quo
you just say yeah I don't know enough
about that but I don't like Biden so I'm
not going to give him the benefit of the
doubt how about you just say I'm not
going to comment for some reason there's
this adamant need among these left
personalities like I'm not talking about
liberals either like leftists we'll be
like I don't like Joe Biden I won't
defend him but this story is not true
and I'm like you don't know anything
about the story why are you defending
him this is what we see it is it is the
establishment narrative line it is it is
you are not approved the New York Times
can come out how about this Politico
magazine can come out outright be like
the Biden family a fortune has tracked
perfectly alongside Biden's career in
government his brother getting contracts
to do construction in Iraq things like
this political made a timeline of it and
then they come out and say never
happened and I'm like I just don't
understand this need to be like nothing
to see here nothing to see here Biden's
perfect now all all of a sudden with the
corporate narrative shifting probably
because they don't want Biden for 20 24.
now I'm wondering if we'll see these
left personalities be like we never
liked Biden what are you talking about
that's exactly what's going to end up
happening because they consider the
mainstream narrative to be their kind of
God in a lot of ways they don't know how
to see things through any other lens
because they track anything else as
propaganda and anything else's uh
anti-establishment which gets a label of
being
like it's against them inherently you
can't ask questions honestly they don't
think you're asking your questions
honestly they think you're asking your
questions to trap them in something
because you have your own agenda rather
than the agenda of just wanting to know
what the hell is going on that's a cult
bro yeah yeah it's because you're evil
and you brought it up and right Wingers
brought up that barisma tape thing so
like therefore it has to be invalid and
you know you've asked two people about
this on air and they haven't seen the
video which is fascinating yeah every
time we ask a liberal or left
personality about the uh quid pro quo
Joe bidenfing fire the prosecutor I got
a billion dollars this I've never heard
of that yeah or they say it's RT it's RT
so it's not reliable because that was
just a clip from the CFR I was like oh
there's a C-SPAN yeah yeah but if you
want to see that clip Now isn't that on
like RT what's on Twitter yeah the
behavior isn't necessarily uh oh solely
on the left uh the react it's a
reactionary behavior and you can get it
from people that are are either it kind
of comes from Fear I mean that's a vague
term but like people that are afraid to
be trapped I think for sure I think
that's a big part of it is like people
like you they feel like you're about to
lead them into a corner where they don't
have enough information and so their
inherent reaction is to just lash out
plus they've had a lot of things held
from them for the last two years three
years after all the social media
networks made sure you didn't know what
was going on with Hunter Biden made sure
you didn't know what was going on with
Prisma I know plenty of people who just
don't even know what that is who don't
know anything that's going on there it's
because but for a public figure an
online figure agreeing with somebody on
the right or the people who shared that
barisma video is worse than the
hypocrisy because who's going to call
them out of the hypocrisy only people
that they perceive to be more on the
right than that that's a cult so like
they don't see this clip like again
people prominent news cover headline
news and politics on a daily basis come
on and they say I've never seen that
clip you had the show with Hunter where
you said that clip doesn't exist and
then you actually smarter was like that
never happened yeah and I was like let
me pull the clip up for you and you can
watch it happen like I don't understand
and he didn't he didn't know and for him
for him that might be fair because he
does more cultural stuff and he admits
that but like it's her and she does
presidential politics on a daily basis
and she's like I've never watched the
clip it's it's it's a question of
why Hunter said that never happened
instead of just being like I'm not
familiar with that but I'm not going to
defend Joe Biden Yes
actually oh man this just happened
Keith obermann saying that Hillary
Clinton never smashed her cell phones he
just got destroyed Nancy mace tweeted
Nancy made this just happened online for
all of us to see and he got community
noted into the sun on Twitter Nancy mace
goes well it's a tweet and right please
feel free because it's awesome it's the
best community note ever he's like you
know that didn't happen right yeah Nancy
May is like Hillary Clinton Donald Trump
gets arrested right a classified
document thing Nancy made this guy yo
Hillary deleted all these emails and
then smashed all of her phones with a
hammer and Keith overen says that never
happened duh that's just lying
it like a couple days ago or what
um it was at least a week ago now like
that the thing is about that is that's
just bad faith they're doing that
because they know that they have large
audiences and there's no way they're
going to agree to what you said because
that tweet then lasts forever so they're
just lying because it's beneficial to
them but they got community noted uh uh
uh through like through the stratosphere
with all these links including a CNN
fact check which is the greatest CNN
fact check to ever air ever on any the
probably the best 60 seconds to ever air
on any cable news ever where CNN had to
get fact checked on air that Hillary
Clinton did in fact smash all of her
devices with a hammer that was from
their supreme court reporters
classic have you seen the fact check
from one of these websites on that
specifically it's that Hillary Clinton
destroyed her devices and they were just
shorted with a hammer but she had a
staffer do it therefore it's like mostly
false right right
she didn't ask
the words are all
almost it's like when you make a claim
it's you better be the most specific as
humanly possible otherwise you're a liar
but they can make any general claim and
then it's like well you know it's
obviously true about you though like you
are especially if they're accusing you
of something you're right about specific
it is so important in this age of if you
think we're in a culture war that you
use the right words that you are very
specific and then Hillary Clinton no I'm
sorry a Hillary Clinton staffer then
took a hammer it was a this ounce hammer
and they smashed it on the ground you
have to literally say the exact thing
otherwise they're going to use that
because they know they don't care if
people read the fact check they just
want people to see that there's a fact
checks on it false partially false or
mostly so this this is a really good so
I pulled the Tweet up uh Nancy mace
Hillary Clinton used a hammer to destroy
evidence she did but you can argue the
semantics of it wasn't her personally
but uh she used bleach bit which is an
open source software to purge a hard
drive make it uh unrecoverable and then
her staff used hammers to destroy the
phone devices he responds you know that
didn't happen right are you okay you
seem to have been hallucinating a lot
lately of course he's fact checked then
by CNN Business Insider and Snopes
proving Hillary Clinton did in fact have
her phones destroyed by a hammer this is
a crazy thing I don't know if they're
lying or that they're just
is the problem
stupid people on the internet
are are tribal and will attract
followers and continue to say stupid
things and then we're just arguing with
brick walls I used to give them the
benefit of the doubt I don't give them
the benefit of the doubt anymore very
rarely do I give them the benefit of the
doubt that I think that he just didn't
know that I think that a lot of them are
just acting in bad faith like like
because because that's because semantics
do matter right he says it didn't happen
but he said it says everything you're
saying is false it's wrong not that your
words are somehow incorrect or Hillary
didn't do personally he's saying
everything you're saying is a lie which
is really important when she said
Hillary Clinton did it and that's not
true her staffer did it and that that's
stupid that's incorrect it's it's if if
you were going to if I claimed
definitively the statement of fact
Hillary Clinton used a hammer to destroy
evidence in a private email server as a
hard statement of fact that that that's
action-proof like judgment proof that is
a fact statement that is true and
provably true
now if I were to say Hillary Clinton
grabbed a hammer in her bare hands and
in a blinding rage shattered those
phones that would not be true
Hillary Clinton did use a hammer to
share the devices she had her staff
first take a hammer and use the hammer
to do it so it's a question of
when it comes to uh statements of fact
whether it's defamation or not what
Nancy May said is a true statement you
might you might argue well you should
clarify Hillary Clinton had staff
members destroy phones with a hammer and
that's probably a better way to phrase
it I don't think she was thinking I
don't think Nancy mace was like how do I
articulate this perfectly I think she
was like Hillary Clinton used the hammer
to do this because she did just if it
does imply that Hillary personally did
it I think clarification is fine Keith
Oberman is either lying or just
this is the problem Keith olberman
clearly is either lying which I think we
all agree may be the case or he's really
really dumb and arrogant now it's
possible he is both dumb arrogant and
light the point of semantic arguments is
to obfuscate the point of the discussion
it's to get you distracted and now
you're no longer talking about what the
actual consequences of the emails are
the point of it is to talk about oh now
we're talking about that's very it's not
waving it it's no longer so now you're
no longer talking about why she should
say the emails why she destroyed any of
this why she deleted all these things
now you're talking about the semantics
of the argument then you don't even get
to the actual debate about what happened
and that's basically social media in a
nutshell and they would do anything in
order to say it's mostly false or
partially false so if you said she
destroyed her blackberries and one of
the seven devices was a Nokia they're
gonna be like um
that's the real question and they use
the red and green color too this is what
Snopes does
I you will come out and say Hillary
Clinton had her phone smashed with a
hammer Snopes won't take that statement
because that statement is is yes or no
they will make up their own question did
Hillary Clinton smash her phone with a
hammer who we're not saying that we're
saying that her she had it done they've
reframed the question so they can then
say mixture well Hillary Clinton did not
personally disturb what I love what they
do is
the headline question the game is one
they do there's also the uh false
qualifier a statement they'll do
um Donald Trump will do a backflip off
the balcony of the White House and land
in a superhero pose and they'll say did
Donald Trump actually do a backflip off
the back into the White House into a
superhero pose comma on Sunday false in
big letters they'll then write 500 words
about the story and the claims at the
bottom and say well it is true he did
the backflip it was on Saturday not
Sunday Lie by structure exactly making
sure that they read you got to click the
CNN link that nobody ever reads to the
end of the article the CNN ones the
famous one where they're like no no pull
that up pull that up
this is from uh this from a while ago
let's play it is it going to play they
might have an ad it might be in their oh
no no why because the FBI had an
exhaustive year-long investigation they
talked to probably dozens and dozens and
dozens of people hours hours and hours
of testimony and the decision not to
recommend uh prosecutions for was
absolutely unanimous was it careless yes
was it a mistake yes as Hillary Clinton
said I should not have done this and if
I ever had to do it again I'd make a
difference it was a criminal no it was
not criminal so I guess that's the
Benchmark now to become president
there's not to be a criminal to become
let's go through the facts unlike 17 17
500 emails that she lied about turning
over the server wipe within weeks of
there being a report the shared a
private server it was white she thought
that c which stands for classified stood
for cookie or something which stands for
classified she thought that dry strikes
are not classified she said that the
reason she used the private servers for
convenience and she only had one device
she used 13 black bears let me finish
and five iPads at least she doesn't just
stick to either Blackberry iPad this is
somebody who is absolutely disqualified
from becoming president they destroyed
blackberries with hammers in the state
department that's not what won the
president
cameras fact check that for me please on
the Fly uh yes they did
[Laughter]
in some way we're used with with her
private email server and they did in
some cases just destroy them with
hammers when they were done which
doesn't do anything to stop the the to
get rid of the date on it you can easily
you can I think if if I'll be very
careful with my words
even after these things are burned and
fires you can still recover data from
them and it's it's the smash it with
hammer absolutely idiotic so the
question then is why is olberman
asserting something that is not true is
it because he's stupid and arrogant or
is he intentionally trying to lie I I
believe that the left has a Munchausen
by proxy relationship with their
audience and that they intentionally lie
because they know that their occult that
will only believe what comes out of the
glowing box and they want that cult to
be manipulatable they need that cult to
be actionable and there's they need them
to be the NPC meme right where you just
take you take the chip out of the back
of the head and you replace it with
black lives matter or the transgender
flag or whatever so you need to be
programmable they want programmable
people George Orwell talks about this uh
in 1984 you need these people to be
programmable the the value of a loyal
servant is what lie will you swallow the
value of the loyal servitude of the left
the Borg is will you say that two plus
two equal equals five that's right there
are five lights
you mentioned the Borg so I had to make
it to Star Trek reference yeah my game
is the famous uh story is when Captain
Picard's being tortured there are four
lights and he's told to say there are
five and he refuses so they keep
torturing him until but he never does it
I was yesterday I was pretty down
thinking like oh actually maybe evil
triumphs over good usually and they just
tell everyone that they were the good
guys like what is this whole I felt so
down and so like hopeless and then I was
like oh how easy it would be to just say
yo go Ukraine I'm all in I'm gonna be on
my Central Bank digital currency just
let me live in peace I don't want to
think about it how easy yeah yes the
Borg the Borg life is easy you sit back
you ever seen Wally you just sit back if
you're a slob you're in your floating
chair have you seen that movie the
school for good and evil so I'm I'm
unable to work so of course I'm just
watching whatever's available and I
watch this movie that and it's basically
it's a it's like a kid teenage movie or
whatever where I don't know what the
point the point of the movie was pretty
dumb but the idea is that in the fairy
tale world there's a school that has an
evil side and a good side and they train
all the prince charmings and they train
all the wicked witches and uh spoiler
alert I'm gonna ruin the story for all
of you
um as to to go on to but you've been
warned spoiler uh the actual outcome of
the story is the good side was corrupted
hundreds of years ago and they had
become Vain and vapid and snooty and
narcissistic and they were gloating
about how good they were but they were
actually fairly corrupted and evil and
so you know that was to your point like
I just watched this movie and that was
the idea they they actually conveyed
that what we think of as good has been
corrupted a long time ago and now it's
just vanity it's like the Biden
Administration you see this all the
torture signaling they just wrap
themselves in the American flag they
wrap themselves in democracy Merrick
Garland said it today he was called on
his today on going to a party
last night at the White House with the
guy he's supposed to be investigating
two guys Jim Biden and Hunter Biden he's
supposed to be investigating both of
them and Merrick Garland is at a party
with them so you said earlier so Merrick
Garland said today sorry to interrupt
you but I just gotta finish his comment
today was if you attack the Department
of Justice you're attacking our
democracy that's what he said if you
question the Department of Justice
you're attacking our democracy and it's
always ours democracy evil and you were
saying smart people would impeach mayor
Garland and let Joe Biden run the reason
that the reporters are going haywire now
and just turning on Biden is because
they feel ashamed about how they were
misled about the submersible story was
that assumption that's what I that's
what I think I think you embarrass them
and make them look bad personally
they're Petty and they get mad at that
and as for the Keith Olbermann thing
remember he's an anchor actor he doesn't
do what you do where you do your
research and then you somebody else puts
the things in the prompter so he might
not be I don't think he's technically
stupid but he might actually not be
lying look I I think I genuinely think
that a large component of the culture
War divide is intelligence
and we were having this joke about doing
a culture War episode where we uh who I
think Sheamus made the joke he said
there's this new podcast where they get
a bunch of you know young girls who have
never was that was that James yeah young
girls who have never been challenged on
anything and then make them look stupid
or whatever and then we were all joking
about how we should have like a 56 year
old PhD conservative Guy debate like
three 18 year old this is the whatever
podcast already do that yeah they did
recently actually with like a 55 year
old PhD he was like a doctor and he was
talking to girls had some credential but
the the joke was that the girls would
actually win because the guy would be
like when you read this study here we
can see this from you know sordinson at
all they talk about and they're like oh
you are so dumb and then we're gonna
start they're being like don't you think
he's stupid say it again said you're
dumb and he's gonna be like okay can you
let me finish my point and they're gonna
laugh then they're gonna start calling
him names and it's going to be like do
you agree that there is a larger
percentage of X when it comes to why in
their bill like you mean like at a pizza
shop he's like no I'm talking about the
economics in this country and I mean
here you want to buy pizzas and he's
going to be like I can't do this it's
impossible these people and they'll be
like that's not hot I'm gonna go have
babies yeah this is the culture War when
we sit down with someone and this is why
you don't see liberals come on shows
like this they rarely want to there's a
small handful that do and they often
grift and then I'm like this is the
problem we run into when we do things
like this when you and I I I it's kind
of like rehashing the show we did this
morning I know that but at the same time
when I see Keith olberman tweeting this
it just it it brings this up to me that
you can't have a conversation with
someone who is you can't argue policy
with someone who can't comprehend policy
and that is the culture War today if you
say something like you know I I think
that we need to I'll give you an example
we're talking about uh the issue of
trans kids and I said we have a study
that shows desistance is 68 to 95 61 to
95 percent uh with no intervention that
would indicate that no intervention is
the safest course of action for children
and Emma did not understand that and
said but the doctors say it's good so we
should do it and if if my point is the
study we have suggests X and the
response is but the government but I
shouldn't say government but the the
authority says it's good we're not you
can't you can't convince someone who
doesn't understand the math of the
science or the argument it just it's a
brick wall I think that's a debate
appeal to Authority it's literally why I
said that over and over and over again
appeal to Authority and that's why the
school system's so good at it right
because they're trained to appeal to
Authority right from the very beginning
so they're just going to defer to
whatever the person in charge says even
if there's data that proves that person
in charge to be incorrect so a really
good example of the challenges we're
facing in the culture war from this
morning for those that listen to this
show you all know that we've actually
had this debate quite a bit over what it
means to to uh support parental rights
Rhonda Santos passes this bill Fuller
legislature the parental rights and
education and then we have the
conversation of what it what does it
mean to be in favor of parents rights
what if the parents want the right to
have a doctor prescribe a sex change to
their child well every conservative of
me that says no you don't have that
right and the government should stop you
okay so it's not parental rights then on
the left I I actually asked Emma what
about the government mandating children
get vaccine she goes well yes I believe
in public health and I'm like okay so
you're not in favor of parental rights
you can you the saying you're you're for
against parental rights is a completely
meaningless statement because everyone's
moral line is going to be completely
different we talk about that quite a bit
she could not grasp that concept and
it's very difficult to have a real
conversation with someone who doesn't
understand the or none of that but can't
actually comprehend basic moral
philosophy so it's if we're if we're
sitting in a room and we're saying let
us break down why we have the policy
should we enact a different policy and
how can we make the lives better for
everybody and they say
duh
I don't understand what you're saying we
can't carry on that conversation she
called hypotheticals right wing right
right she was like I'm not going to
engage in your right wing tactic of
hypotheticals it was wild to hear that
so but this is exactly the point you get
a bunch of people when I was mentioning
the conservative PhD guy and a bunch of
young girls who are just giggling and
laughing and saying you're dumb there's
no conversation to be had now here's the
real challenge those three giggling dumb
vapid teenage girls have three votes to
that conservative phd's one vote and
this is what we're dealing with in the
culture war and I bring this up because
I'm seeing like the Keith Urban thing
when it comes to issues of barisma when
it comes to issue of issues of Hillary
Clinton doing these things these are not
left or right-wing things these are
things that are discernably true that we
have questions about I can sit here and
be like Barack Obama killed Abdullahi in
a drone strike in a civilian restaurant
in Yemen and he should be he should be
criminally charged and prosecuted and if
found guilty be be held accountable for
murder of an American citizen Donald
Trump ordered a Commando right in Yemen
which reportedly according to the family
resulted in the death of an
eight-year-old girl abdullahi's sister
that should be investigated if it is
brought to an investigation Trump should
be charged same as Obama however I think
that story might be a bit less credible
than the Obama one which we know for a
fact did happen they've admitted to I
still think both warrant the same legal
jurisprudence I can say those things
but for some reason when you have a
conversation with someone like Keith
Olbermann or many liberals they will
just be alike
the barisma video never happened and I'm
like you you know you're making that up
because we have the video to play it did
happen and they're saying he was never
being investigated but we know for a
fact and there's a sworn affidavit from
shoken there were a dozen investigations
into into my closet instead of actually
engaging with you they'll either be
unable to actually comprehend the the
moral philosophy or the math and science
behind what you're arguing and then
they'll just lie I think the tribalism
nature of it short circuits their brain
just a little bit like you can't
actually go forward when you have a dog
in the fight of who wins so it's like if
if we're okay with the idea that Obama
is prosecuted for war crimes and you're
also you also have to be okay with the
idea that Trump would be prosecuted for
the same thing if he did indeed do that
same thing but if they have a dog in the
fight if they say no I cannot let Barack
Obama or Joe Biden or whoever uh fall
because I believe so strongly in the
leftist cause I guess it's not really
liberal it's neoliberal at best like you
can't allow new data because you're just
not going to believe that that's
actually true you just think they're
trying to get one over on you because
they believe that your every bit as
tribal as they are sort of but I but I
do think cognitive in capabilities is a
strong uh uh is a stronger component of
this a couple examples when we had Matt
bender on he kept saying you think trans
people don't exist which is a nonsense
statement that conveys no no logical
thought other than it's a thing the left
says and when I responded with they
certainly exist I think trans kids exist
we've had trans people on this show what
are you saying he didn't have a response
because if you're not smart enough to
actually understand a position you'll
just say thing then we had Lance from
the surf son and he said you're for
forced birth and I said what does that
mean and he did not have a response
because it's a thing they say there's no
actual substance behind it it is very
much like an NPC in a video game you
walk up to and and he says welcome to
the end and then you'll you can type in
whatever you want how was your day today
and they'll say the insult swears and
you'll never respond to you properly
like they never plastic they never get
past the slogan right so they hear the
slogan repeated enough times on social
media it's almost like your brain
bypasses actually putting thought into
what that means so it is kind of like
what you're saying they are just kind of
programmed and I I do think there is an
aspect because like I don't I'm a dummy
I'm I'm I'm a dummy but I'm also not
biases to I Don't Really Care who's
guilty or who or I care about who's
guilty who's innocent I don't have a dog
in the fight of whether it's Trump
whether it's Obama I just want it to be
I want the facts but I everyone in this
room right now and I would say the
overall majority of guests we have on
the show can understand a concept of a
plus b equals c so if I say here's my
position they go oh okay I understand I
disagree with you whereas these
conversations with these lefties is just
like Blank Stare confusion and then
nonsense response I really think a lot
of it more just has to do with the
tribal I think this the tribalism short
circuits their brain but also maybe they
don't engage in enough healthy debate
with people that they generally agree
with people here are going to agree and
disagree on various things all the time
right like we could have a debate on any
topic here tonight we may fall in line
on something since see eye to eye on
other things we'll see things
differently I don't think that happens
to them that very much I think they go
with consensus so Ben Rhodes did an
interview he was Barack Obama's National
Security advisor and Ben Rhodes is the
guy who's also found weeping when
Hillary Clinton lost in 2016. do you
remember that video he's actually
sobbing out back
and uh Ben Rhodes does this really
instructive interview about how they
were able to get so many lies
manufactured and merchandised and
laundered in the Obama Administration
about the Iran deal about what they were
doing in the Middle East about the drone
strikes and he says oh guys do you know
who makes up reporters you think it's a
bunch of Walter cronkites shuffling
around with dandruff on their jackets
being like well actually in the corner
era he's like no and I'm paraphrasing
Ben Rhodes
he says it's 27 year olds they don't
know anything they've done one campaign
gig that's it one campaign gig for
Bloomberg and they come here for the
cocktail parties they'll believe
anything I tell them and I can
merchandise anything I want about the
Iran deal to them I can tell them any
lie I want and they will just print it
in Bloomberg it's worse than that you
get some 24 year old fresh out of
college fifty thousand dollar a year
starting journalist and you go to them
and say
I am you work in the government you say
I'm going to be your Source you are
going to have all of the inside scoops
on all of these stories and it's going
to make you a household name and then
they go oh boy I have a source and then
they're going to go to their boss and
they're gonna be like here's my source
in the government they'll tell me
whatever I ask and that person's gonna
be like we are gonna get so many clicks
so they'll come to them and say Source
says that Donald Trump you know kicked
the dog and they'll be like well then
write the source said so and then we
can't be sued for defamation because
it's a true statement not that he kicked
the dog but that a source said he did
and that's my favorite was sources
familiar with Trump's thinking you
remember all those stories yeah they're
just writing nonsense garbage yeah so my
my my main point with all of this was
you know and we're going to be doing
these these these culture War shows
every Friday so it's going to be a whole
lot more of this
I really think that the challenge we
face is
the culture War may be
people of this social media is granting
access of people of low cognitive
function to spaces of high-level
discourse
and we respectfully allow them to have
these conversations but it's like a 55
year old you know PhD political
scientist having a debate with three 18
year old teenage girls who like don't
don't do anything other than go on Tick
Tock and Instagram that's the and that's
it and and you know here's the funny
thing those 18 year old girls they'll
tell you all about BLM they'll tell you
all about you know Pride because they're
on social media oh they posted the black
Square yeah they were excited to post
that black square and then they'll be
like I know because I saw the video yeah
and you you can go to them and be like
here's the study it says you're wrong
they'll be like nope I'm right yeah it's
called cognitive dissonance at least one
way to term it and I think it is a good
thing to have those conversations even
when they feel fruitless sometimes
because it doesn't all happen at once
you don't change someone's mind in a
moment every once in a while you do but
it's pretty rare it usually takes time
and a lot of it is just about making
people calm I think that's a big part of
the culture war and winning the culture
War I think the goal uh so for those
that watch the culture War show today go
to youtube.com timcast check it out it
was live uh Emma vigiland uh Sean uh
Fitzgerald AKA actual Justice Warrior we
were all having this conversation I will
say again I felt a little bad because it
did seem like two two versus one because
I wasn't intending on on that but I
think there's one really important point
that people need to understand about why
I want to do shows like this I do not
believe we will convince Emma or anyone
at the the majority report or any
liberal or leftist of any of our
positions but I don't care
what I think is important is that we
produced a show where Emma said that she
wanted children to be able to watch porn
at the age of 10 years old and so I'm
like I don't I don't need you to argue
that point to me I don't care what I
need to do is when I'm talking to my my
you know my friend from back home in
Chicago who's telling it never happened
I'm gonna play that clip of me being
like we should not be showing a book to
children that contains blow jobs and
have this person alive say we should and
it's fine and they're okay with it and
I'm like that's all I needed I needed
for you to say it so I can prove to
people you believe these things so they
can I'm like you're allowed to believe
that uh and she did adamantly defend uh
kink education and pornography for
children and I'm like you can absolutely
be be on board with it I'm not telling
you to dis to stop believing any of that
I think it's disgusting I just need you
to say it say it right there to the
camera for everyone to watch so that
finally when I go to my friend and say
you know these people want put porn in
schools they'll say that's not sure all
black let me play the video for you let
me let me show you the clip where they
and here's the book and now they now
they're like oh I guess they do support
those things the Borg will end up ending
your career so to come here today I flew
into Virginia and Virginia by every
right should have a Democrat Governor
why don't they many would argue that
Terry McAuliffe was just unpopular or
whatever nope actually it goes directly
back to a single point in time there
previous Democrat Governor on a radio
show live like we are now said that
children should be born and then the
mother should stare at her child in the
bassinet and decide whether it should
die he said they should comfort the
babies keep them comfortable and then
the mother should have a decision of a
post-birth abortion I tried to explain
that to people because I'm I'm from
Minnesota guy's name what's the governor
uh Northam so in Minnesota they just
passed similar legislation right and I
was trying to explain to my friend this
was 2018 when this happened right it was
2018 or 2019. it seems like that sounds
crazy like that's a that's a one-off
that's where I'm like no this is
becoming mainstream and in a couple
years it will make its way to places
like Minnesota where the government is
Shifting very very farther left with uh
what's his name um the waltz right so
it's like you you don't get to just
laugh it off and stick your head in the
sand and say this isn't happening or I
don't think it's that huge appeal like
it's a it's like there is an argument to
me like depending on how politically
active the person you're having this
discussion with you have to watch your
tone because if you get too because
these things upset people right you're
like no this is real and you shove it in
their face a lot of times people just
shut down and they don't want to they
don't want to have that discussion right
that's a lot to just throw on someone at
a moment's notice but I think it goes to
what you're saying about keeping people
calm because you have to keep them calm
and informed because as these things
continue to happen as these things
continue to grow in other legislations
you need the evidence that these people
actually think this way because it does
sound ridiculous because that's child
sacrifice by every definition that's the
sacrifice of a child that's child
sacrifice it's not like I'm it's not a
pejorative okay metaphorical child it's
a literal child sacrifice like Aztec
level child sacrifice is what the
governor of Virginia advocated for and
so Democrats need to own that because
that's their party and you need to
absorb the fact that that's what you
represent they just run fact checks
saying it didn't happen it didn't happen
it didn't happen and then what they'll
do is they'll run a headline says didn't
Ralph Thumb in on a video advocate for
and explain post birth abortion false
and then what they'll say is the
governor was referring to babies who
were born with abnormalities who could
not survive on their own and need a
resuscitation he was not talking about
abortion weasel words the point is you
you can't abort a baby that's already
been born is he a murderer exactly
sanctioned death if you make it legal
and so they they can say he wasn't
talking about abortion because the fact
of the matter is he's talking about
killing a baby but he was talking about
killing children that had like severe
deformities and wouldn't survive I don't
think so no no no
Mom's decision he was talking about a
bill on the floor of the Virginia Senate
they had written that bill and the bill
was written in a way that the mom could
decide that once the baby's born she
doesn't want it there was there was a
judge that asked um what was her name
was it Nancy Tran was her name uh do you
want someone affected real quick he said
something at this rate with your bill
a woman could get an abortion up to the
point of birth and she goes there are no
restrictions and he goes the baby is
crowning and she goes there are no
restrictions yeah and so that's what he
was talking to specifically was it was
it it was like if they botched it a late
term and then the baby was out of the
womb then what would you do I think was
the context for North I'm saying yeah I
always make a decision it's Kathy Tran I
would say Nancy for some reason so
you're saying they're they're taking a
mother who's going through something
that is like physically traumatic right
the entire process right and she starved
oxytocin and her body's going through
all these things they're saying hey you
want to keep the kid that's insane
that's insane it's insane that's insane
but oh Snopes did you see it uh the
claim Virginia governor Ralph Northam uh
quote stated he would execute a baby
after birth most
just mostly false because it's ambiguous
they don't make us play the clip aren't
you it's a Alex Jones was on our show
and did a great reality Governor Ralph
Northam say he would execute a baby
after birth they put in quotes and they
put mostly false so it's kind of true
you did not state he would execute him
see nobody said he said that you know
and the ambiguity of northern's remarks
about late-term abortions which has not
since clarified race questions about
what exactly he was proposing or
advocating he literally all right do we
have the clip do they do they even play
the clip oh man hey props to them for
playing this
can we uh bill would remove the
following statutes trap or targeted
regulations of abortion let me see if I
can is worthy of an abortion
I'm not going to play the whole thing
like they they should play this the
northern clip is short and if you can
find that that's short you know the baby
will be kept comfortable next turn back
to NBC 4's Julie Carey and governors you
know the issue of abortion rights
emerges every year in the general
assembly session this year no exception
there was a very contentious Committee
hearing yesterday when Fairfax County
delegate Kathy Tran made her case for
lifting restrictions on third trimester
abortions as well as other restrictions
now in place and she was pressed by
Republican delegate about whether her
bill would permit an abortion even as a
woman is essentially dilating ready to
give birth and she answered that it
would permit an abortion at that stage
of Labor do you support her measure and
explain her answer yeah and I'm you know
I wasn't there uh Julie and I certainly
can't speak for uh delegate Tran but
um I will tell you one uh first thing I
would say this is why decisions such as
this should be made by providers
programming position here's the
programming the program answer the
mothers and fathers that that are
involved
um there are you know when we talk about
third trimester abortions these are done
uh with the consent of obviously the the
mother with the consent uh of the
Physicians more than one physician by
the way and it's done in cases where
there may be severe deformities there
may be a a fetus that's non-viable so in
this particular example if a mother is
in labor I can tell you exactly uh what
would happen the infant would be
delivered the infant would be kept
comfortable uh the infant would be
resuscitated if if that's what the
mother and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
Physicians and the mother so so I think
this was really blown out of proportion
but again we want prepared not to be
involved in these types of decisions we
want the decision to be made by the the
modelers and their providers and and
this is why Julie that legislators most
of whom are men by the way shouldn't be
telling a woman what she shouldn't be
doing
it
should have to weigh in as is currently
required she's trying to lift that
requirement well I think it's always
easy to get a second opinion and for for
at least I wanted that to play out to
show you that the context did not Circle
back and that there was no other further
clarifying points and I want to stress
he outright said
the context of the conversation was no
restriction abortions up to the point of
birth and he said yes and the doctor and
the mother should make that decision and
then he goes on to explain a
circumstance in which the baby is
delivered and brought into another room
and I'm sorry for interrupting my
headphones cut out I thought that the
clip had ended sorry about that so that
this is I mean be be capable have the
moral fortitude to call people demons
be capable of calling out demonic
blackened spiritual activity when you
see it they want to desensitize you they
want you to think that this is normal
this is not normal this is depraved evil
from the pit of Hell do have the
capacity as a moral person you don't
even have to be a Christian Muslim Jew
doesn't matter to me as a moral person
you should be able to stand up for the
life of a small helpless infant who was
just born as I have held my little
newborn babies in my hand and say you do
not deserve to die and someone who is
wishing to take your life is a literal
demon thank God that man and his party
lost in the great state so I want to
point out the Snopes headline mostly
false he did not state he would execute
a baby after birth well that's an
opinion statement if we if we said that
he verbatim said he would execute baby
that's false but if I were to say
Northam talked about executing babies
and said that that's exactly what would
happen that is a true statement snopes
is obfuscating this they say the
ambiguity of his remarks about late-term
abortions what she asked could a woman
get an abortion at the point of Labor he
says well yeah you know it's up to the
doctor and the mother to decide if it's
up to the doctor for the mother of the
side he's basically saying that they
could choose yes if need be so the
simple point is the left immediately
goes to he's talking about deformity and
abnormality and my response was like you
think deformed people should be killed
like that's crazy to me like I don't
think so if the baby's alive don't kill
it what a great question okay so should
all deform people be killed like what
about a 21 year old deformed person what
does that mean this is the crazy thing
people in wheelchair be deformed me and
this guy over here pro-choice arguing
with a leftist about this stuff and it's
the weirdest position to be in there
it's because there's no moral position
behind their words they are just
regurgitating what they were told and
they're trying to you know what you know
what Snopes lies about this this is the
point I was making the reason why I want
to do these shows why we had I believe
netbender as well as Lance say there
should be no restrictions at all on
abortion even up to the point of birth
let them say it because I'm not here to
try and convince them otherwise I need
them to just say to the camera so then
we can show people they actually believe
that you got to point out where this
leads though this leads to Eugenics this
is simply Eugenics Iceland this is
they've Eugenics out Down syndrome
that's right that's exactly and and the
third right to the exact same people in
the comment sections when you talk about
that are crazy just like yeah of course
you should get rid of the people like
they actually believe that like the
people in the comment sections of anyone
on Twitter talking about that absolutely
I just want to point out that I hate the
way that Northam talks like the way that
he answered that question it's like this
Lefty new speak and you should really
like listen in so the first thing he
says was I wasn't there when the
question was there's a viral video of
this woman answering questions it's like
who cares if you were there I wasn't
there but I can see the video so it's a
misdirect all right off the bat he says
sent two or three times because consent
is a positive word like are you against
consent what's wrong with you right and
it all that leads up to him own goaling
himself and saying well the baby will be
delivered and you know we put a blanket
around it and then we'd have a
conversation about killing it it's it's
the craziest thing yeah right it's the
same but he masks it and all this like
distracted here's CBS news from 2017 uh
what is it okay they obvious gate the
headline inside a country where Down
syndrome is disappearing Iceland is on
the verge of eliminating Down syndrome
okay oh now hold on
we don't want people to have Down
syndrome but we don't kill people for
having right the left advocates for the
termination of a life if it does have
Down syndrome I do not believe that
having some what they would describe as
well as Down syndrome I don't believe
any view of that negative or positive
it's mostly negative warrants the death
or a cessation of life that's insane to
me
but the but the left and and Iceland for
instance they literally argue a a goal
of abortion is to end the life of
someone who has Down syndrome to me that
is psychotic and I'm I'm pro-choice
traditionally not in the current leftist
sense because which makes no sense I
think they've gone off the off the wall
of the Rails the whole point of him
bringing up the part about deformities
is because what he's preying on is the
idea that you would think that nobody
would do it if there weren't deformities
right why would somebody do that not
realizing that most of the time when
this stuff is having that's not
necessarily going to be the situation
that's going to come of it so when they
leave that conversation they don't leave
that Converse they don't leave that clip
watching that clip thinking he just
advocated for people to be able to abort
abort a child after it's born what they
leave with is him saying well he's
saying that if somebody's deformed then
why would you do you understand someone
says he said most of these cases are
deformities and other problems but the
question was blank at all no
restrictions and he did not say he was
against him he said he was in favor he
just shifted
what about when your deformity is
wearing a Maga hat yeah or like having a
sixth toe right what about when your
deformity is that your dad was a
conservative what about that well what
about when that's the deformity because
that's how this always goes it always
goes like that and that's the way it
always go the deformity for Margaret
Sanger Was a Race she didn't like and
that is why Planned Parenthood was
started with the express intent of
getting rid of a racial population that
Margaret Sanger didn't like and that's
why Planned Parenthood was started in
the inner cities but these are facts
these are straight facts with some
Planned Parenthood and where they come
from and what they were intended to do
what's amazing is the Eugenics is that
if you're in favor of curing Down
syndrome like you know some kind of
medication that would like raise their
IQ so they no longer have Down syndrome
uh they would be against you they call
you and ableist like you're a bigot
what's wrong with you but killing them
before they even exist like eliminating
them in that way well that's woman's
body woman's Choice like what's wrong
with you like why do you hate women so
it's it's wild like if you know they
went after um that autism organization
because they had finding a here still on
their website also I mean that's very
common also in the deaf Community
because they consider it part of their
identity so a lot of they don't want the
cochlear implant they don't want to
change it because they've considered
part of who they are right so they're
they're saying the same thing amongst
about learning disabilities which is not
inherently but but it's one thing for
you to not want it but it's very
interesting that they don't they find
the idea of curing deafness to be
offensive like yeah I think it would be
great like designer I'm open to this
conversation about designer babies uh
crispr Technologies like genetic
technology of things in the womb babies
in the womb things but creatures in the
womb of any kind
um and I think if you could cure
blindness or deafness in the womb early
on of course you would do that I I can't
imagine anyone why anyone would would
want not to do that if it was safe if it
was tested there's like a there's a Zoo
in Tampa and there's a small animal that
has there's a there's like a manatee
that was born with like a little flipper
Nemo yeah like a Nemo right and these
manatees are really cute and it's in
Florida right so there's a big Manatee
tank and you go underwater and it's cool
lighting and there's neat music and you
watch the manatees eat these giant balls
of lettuce and they just gobble up these
letters it has this huge animal only eat
lettuce anyway you see this little this
famous little Manatee always got a
little little flipper
you're arguing for the killing of that
manatee
like like what you're doing as a leftist
is you're saying that you should have
seen the manatees flipper and as soon as
it was more as a little teeny little
ball of a goo a joyous little ball or a
panda or wherever you happen to be the
pandas in DC they're very famous you're
taking the panda who's born that's a
miracle because it's very hard to breed
pandas in captivity and you're taking
that Panda and you're like oh but the
band is black stripe isn't exactly down
the middle of its face so
see ya and you take it out back you keep
it comfortable while you uh take it out
back an Old Yeller that thing if that's
what you're arguing you're arguing that
these deformities apply the deformities
to uh cute little animals nine you see
how monstrous it's this logic well I'm
actually against the pandas like if we
set this whole thing up for you to hook
up and you just refuse then honestly
like you kind of don't deserve like to
continue I understand like tribal hard
life where it is like we are on the move
and if we do not keep moving we are
gonna our entire tribe will be wiped out
and you're like your baby is not able to
breathe properly it's not coming with us
kind of like I understand where it comes
from but we don't live in that Society
right now we don't although but still I
I still support you know a woman's right
to choose early on in the pregnancy
personally uh up to like you know what
what is it 16 weeks or something when
it's still in early development that's
my personal thing and if you find out
that but I think a lot of times autism
doesn't or uh Down syndrome doesn't show
up until later in the pregnancy so that
conversation what I was just making is
kind of a moot point like I don't know
what point does that start to show up in
the pregnancy I don't know either I
wanna I wanna play this very short clip
from Freedom Tunes because we're big
fans of Sheamus so Sheamus we're playing
your clip let me unmute this and just
play this for you
[Music]
yeah Democrat man I knew you would come
save me what seems to be the problem I'm
poor and have a rough family situation I
know just the trick oh boy
where did you go I traveled back in time
12 years and had your mom get an
abortion
[Music]
oh my God or if it's Canada now you can
just choose made
perfect get that camera out of my face
yeah that's right you got paid shout out
Sheamus yeah uh I thought that was
really good the the argument that a
child would be poor is not an argument
for ending the life of the child yes
that and it's just I don't know I had to
play that clip it's too good oh I looked
up downstairs usually detected between
10 and 13 weeks in the first trimester
sometimes and I've heard really horrible
stories from a lot of parents where they
were told by their doctors the child is
sickly it's not going to make it so you
need to get an abortion and then they
said no and then they had had a normal
healthy kid what a strange term Down
syndrome like as opposed to up syndrome
like down like is that because it's down
I think it's named for someone it's just
down there's no s I thought it was Downs
also to Down syndrome so my so my uh
wife and I had uh our second child last
year and uh the doctor comes in and this
is something that is horrible for every
parent you get all these checkups and
you get the ultrasound and they do these
very sophisticated ultrasounds the
doctor comes in and goes I'm really
sorry but but you got a problem
that you have a let me see if I can
remember this right and aortic
um some type of aortic afibrillation
where your daughter's heart is not
developing correctly
and you'll worst case scenario she won't
be able to to survive when she's born uh
best case scenario we could maybe do we
could maybe do a
open heart surgery when she's born and
so we'll have the team there and we'll
try and we'll make sure that like you
know we'll have the open heart surgeons
there no promises that's what they tell
us
no promises
and that's what the medical experts at
this very sophisticated very good
Hospital in an excellent Hospital A
Private Hospital Catholic Hospital told
us I'm not trying to put them on blast
because my daughter was born and she was
perfect
she was perfect she was a perfect angel
from God and then we brought her in she
was breathing her heart rate was perfect
even after every expert told us we're
gonna need to do open heart surgery on
your daughter when she's born we bring
her in for her first week uh checkup to
check this specific heartbeat issue
where her heart valves weren't
developing correctly and they're like
it's fixed
it's a miracle wow it's your daughter's
heart is the exact words were perfect
now I'm not saying that anyone advocated
for me to get an abortion they never
pushed us to that
but what if you are young and what if
you didn't know any better and what if
you didn't have the same life that my
wife and I have and you heard that
and well man I'm just gonna carry this
baby to term and it's not gonna have a
heart and won't be able to survive and
then everyone in the media and all of
these prominent influences are alike
don't feel guilty
don't feel guilty just just no no this
is you living your truth and you
actually you're doing the kid a favor
and so my beautiful bubbly one-year-old
named Juliet would not exist today
uh because medical science
which was wrong which was 100 wrong or
I'm just the recipient of a miracle I'll
tell you the other way is that I'm a
recipient of Miracle I'll tell you and
and and God healed my child I think
right either way either way they were
wrong and my child is the I couldn't
imagine my life without her
conservatives need to understand that
you're not going to legislate cultural
morality
this idea that you can make something
illegal is is nonsense marijuana is
illegal everybody in the country smoking
it like crazy so this idea that you
would approach the issue of abortion by
saying we should just completely ban it
out right I can certainly understand the
pro-life argument well you you would get
rid of a lot of it sure
you need to focus on mending the culture
I think Ron Paul said it well I think
was Ron Paul he said it should be it
shouldn't be illegal it should be
Unthinkable if you have a culture that
gloats and laughs and mocks and does
like what's that comedian who had a
Netflix and said everyone gets abortion
so you get an abortion show wolf I think
and I think Lena Dunham said that
although she'd never been pregnant she'd
wished she had gotten abortion or
something that effect that is a diseased
culture that is like a culture that is
sick and in need of help so that we get
to the point where we say like that
shouldn't happen why is it happening
that people are promoting these things
that are bad and then you know we say
let's not do those things
we have a movement to destigmatize
everything because stigma is considered
a dirty word but stigma is actually
valuable and we should use it more often
in specific circumstances like shaming
is also a good public tool for bad
behavior like we need societal pressure
to disincentivize poor behavior and it
goes well beyond this topic in my
opinion yeah I feel like we could take
another two hours and talk about the
porn industry and making that illegal
part of it but it's 9 30 we're probably
going to Super chats pretty soon I don't
want to take us too deep in but like
it's your take what do you mean well
like you porn there's potentially
underage people on there and it's not
very well and it's like he's someone
like even I think Emma on the show was
saying that it should be illegal for
nine or ten-year-olds to have I wasn't
there and I didn't see you I'm not
putting words in your mouth Emma but
that uh to have access to to be able to
see pornography like you were writing
specifically genderqueer
and then she I she she didn't give like
a good direct answer because they shoot
you can't but she said that I was in
favor of censorship when I argued that
children shouldn't have access to books
that depict Kink and porn and I said yes
I am and she was so your support
censorship I was like of course I do I
was like first of all if you watch the
show and if you watched my show at any
point you'd know that we actually pray
censorship all the time when we talk
about how some things you I was like so
do you want Playboy for kids in schools
do you want Hustler like what's the line
this book is teaching children about
having Kink Kink sex with an auto
androphile children should not be
reading that and and she actually said
that it she defended the teacher who
gave instruction on using Grindr to 10
year olds I'm like she said it was a
good book right she said this book is is
called this this book is gay I said it
was a good book and I'm like kids should
not be learning how to go on Grindr to
have sex with adults we need a
revolution in sexual education in our
current Society because of the way
pornography is proliferated for
nine-year-olds to gain access to on the
internet if their parents aren't
watching or if they go to school and a
kid has a cell phone and I I don't know
if if making it illegal like you're
saying if we can legislate it away I
mean you can take you porn down and that
will reduce the amount of it but it
doesn't mean that it's not gonna We I
people will still share things on their
phones uh kids will still share pictures
of even themselves which is still
illegal uh but if they were to when they
went after PornHub it eliminated a good
portion of their content because they
did not verify the ages of a lot of the
girls
I don't think that we should let me put
this way when the internet first emerged
nobody cared because it was small and
they were like nobody uses it there were
those there's those famous videos where
the newscasters are alike this internet
thing's not taking off and there and
then someone was explaining how you
could buy a movie ticket and he goes
what's the point I can walk down there
and hand him cash you're wasting my time
this is never going to take off and then
of course the internet is everything now
we need to recognize that we are not
we're no longer talking about someone
walking in a dark alley with a dirty
magazine and those things sometimes
happen we're talking about someone
buying a billboard in Times Square of of
goatse or something like that and any
kid can just stumble upon it and go ah
and we probably need to say yeah you
can't do that but we but I gotta say we
have become in many ways it's it's our
it's anarcho tyrannic we've become
authoritarian in a bunch of ways and
horrifying libertarian in very very bad
ways so we need a cohesive culture that
permits Liberties in some areas and
restricts things in other areas with it
backwards right now we we opened
internet access to insane psychotic porn
where kids are getting access to it
should not be capable it shouldn't be
able to happen but we're just like well
it's free speech it's legal you can show
all of it and then it's like okay
there's a moral question about the
limits here you might say don't tread on
me or whatever and my argument is you're
literally allowing people to sell
graphic images to kids and we need a way
to deal with that there are serious
challenges when we saw the sisa and um
do you remember these uh yes I do
remember
they they were under the guise of child
protection we're going to try and censor
free speech on the internet so figuring
that out is very very very difficult but
I don't accept sisa sisa that we're in
this era where everyone just knows and
accepts that a 10 year old kid with
their phone is going to see
do you want to talk about dark stuff
they can get access on their phone to
videos of murders happening of like
snuff films yo when I was a kid back in
my day I'll tell you what
these are things a VHS Legend it was
like faces of faces
now if a kid a little kid wants to watch
someone die they just Google it yeah and
and but for us it was like dude John's
got Faces of Death no way and you might
might get to see it maybe I never
actually saw it I only heard about my
friends who one time saw it at this one
place you'd go to the you go to the you
go to the video store and they would
have a room with a curtain where it's
like you got to be 18 to go in that room
kids could not go in that room so you
couldn't see these things I was just the
other day I was on I was looking on
Twitter as the video of the rapper dying
on stage and I'm just like uh he they're
saying it's like people are like the
conspiracy is that it was from vaccine
injury right but Like Rappers just on
stage had like I don't know if it's a
heart attack just kills over and dies
and I was like was it a big show uh is I
mean it was it was like uh I don't
remember his name but uh it's like a
Houston rapper and yeah just it's like a
45 second clip you see him like he's
performing he kind of stops he hesitates
and then he just Keels over and dies I
the founding fathers of the United
States were dudes like these guys were
legit as far as I can tell the even if
evil wins they will tell you they were
the good guys but I think they were
pretty good the Constitution stands for
itself what would they have done with
this internet he was a big dude yeah
he's a big dude he's not super he's not
like morbidly obese he's obese but you
watch the video and you see him he his
body just kind of tenses up and he looks
like he's like he stops and then he just
Keels over like I'm I'm literally
legitimately
they deleted on my Twitter account the
video of the Immigrant stabbing people
in France I think they deleted that
Twitter radio and and do you agree with
that that's tough because Twitter is not
a space for children it is a it is a
newsreel so I think a sensitivity filter
with an age restriction probably would
be the appropriate way to deal with it
but Twitter was probably reacting to
negative to fears of advertising as a
negative press it's simple put a put a
sensitive filter on it make it so that
not only do you have to be signed in to
see it you got to press a filter button
and enter your age so it's triple
layered and then it keeps the
newsworthiness available for people you
make it so ads will never appear next to
it and kids shouldn't be able to get
access to it assuming they're logged in
an appropriate age we do got to go super
chats though but that is that is a
there's a difficult question there all
right I'm not your buddy guy says our
socialist Healthcare isn't great here in
Alberta a woman who needs an organ is
being left to die because she won't get
the covet jab even our federal courts
have refused to hear the case
wow he goes on to say congrats to Benny
for the one million Subs finally I hope
people still hear what happens here in
Canada once Bill c-11 comes into effect
we'll find out soon I guess we'll
welcome China da
congratulations on a million was that
did you you just hit a millionaire this
week yes oh wow fantastic Sammy Johnson
show on YouTube or on Twitter on YouTube
nice dude at Benny Johnson they're gonna
send you the gold plaque is that what we
we have uh many gold uh uh Awards we use
one to prop the window open
shout out to YouTube you know look
YouTube's been uh YouTube demonetized
you know we we should talk about this
yeah we brought it up uh five days ago
and it's it's it's it's and Glenn
greenwald's tweeting about it Elon
responded to it YouTube unquestionably
is interfering in the election for the
benefit of the democratic party hands
down Luke ridkowski who's been on the
show all the time and he he talks on his
show about the exact same thing he talks
about when he's on this show well he he
might get a little spicier in some areas
and talk more on foreign policy and they
claimed reused content which is a false
demonetization
Luke does very similar videos to me
where he shows articles and comments on
the news
and they they claimed it was reuse kind
of reuse content is for when you take
someone else's video and post it to your
channel without doing anything with it
so yeah here's the thing that got Luke
and I dm'd him I said Luke hit me up
dude I know exactly what happened to you
because I have in my channel when you're
doing shorts which YouTube is pushing
and pushing a lot of eyeballs to shorts
you need to be in those shorts and you
need to be commenting on them
Luke was posting Luke was posting full
minutes of other people's videos we used
Luke was posting clips and that happened
that hit my channel too so about a year
ago without wait a minute so you need
his face in the corner or something you
need to comment on it right dude you got
to see this photo of this kid in
California you can't believe he did this
at a BLM rally you show the clip and
then you're like dude that's that's
crazy that's what you're right and you
you react right to to this YouTube needs
you to be in the Creator needs to be in
the content I'm not trying to do shorts
Luke was doing for YouTube shorts this
happened to my channel channel so
YouTube shorts is brand is a relatively
new product you just upload it corrected
Joe Biden falls down the stairs you just
slap in the clip in there you just send
it out I wanted to talk with Luke I'm
like dude this is what this is what it
is you need to you can't just upload any
clip to shorts you got to be a part of
that and I will say stand corrected
apologize to YouTube in that regard and
then criticize YouTube for taking down
the video with RFK Jr and Jordan
Peterson which is a contending
presidential candidate having his
opinions taken down with massive
approval in the polls that right there
is interference I'm just trying to be a
dude screwed up I'm just trying to be a
dude and say this is how like Luke this
is how you fix that that issue
um of the demonetization and the
unoriginal content because it happened
to my Channel all right let's grab some
more Super chats
Ocho says glad to have you back just
like all leftists that woman was hard to
listen to because she kept putting words
in everyone's mouth and wouldn't let
others talk but it needs to be done to
further the conversation and respect it
well look I appreciate her coming out I
know the majority report people really
do want to come on this show uh out of
all the people we invite they're the
ones who are begging to come on the show
uh Emma hit us up and we were like
absolutely we'll have you on but I do
want to point out my favorite moment in
the show was when she repeatedly at she
she asked me why what I liked about
desantis's policy and then I started
talking about coveted restrictions and
Leadership and then she interrupted me
and said no policy and then I said okay
well the culture War stuff obviously
matter a lot and then when I brought up
specifically she goes no what is he
doing now and I'm like okay well
removing these books she goes I don't
want to hear about anecdotes I want to
talk about the bigger picture and I'm
like you literally asked me for a
specific example that I gave you one and
you got mad at me for it so it was like
what I think happened was I believe that
she was given talking points before the
show likely by Sam or someone else at
the majority report and she had a list
of things that she was Cedar all along
well and so the issue is if she's told
to say something
and then I respond she won't know how to
respond to it because she only has one
canned question and no can't I gotta
watch the interview so it's getting it's
building up I've only seen like 15
minutes of it so far so I'm excited to
watch this saying like what do you
support about DeSantis and my response
is does he even have a presidential
campaign I don't even know I don't know
what he's running on and I'm not for the
guy why are you asking me this there's
but but I assure you they'll edit all of
these things to be like here are gotchas
that don't make sense yeah so a lot of
it on Twitter so far Tim are you being
triggered right now I've loaded my voice
after I've aggravated you right oh
there's a term for that in Psychology
where you get the other person upset and
then you're like you're so upset what's
wrong with you I call it NPR voicing
when they go to the MBR voice
right it's funny I was watching a clip
with Joe Rogan I was watching The Joker
podcast and then he goes one guy asks
him a question I can't remember the
question he goes what are you doing are
you trying to make a viral clip right
now he's like yes yes now his friend
probably wasn't doing I think he Joe was
being silly but this is literally why we
don't have have these people on the show
because they intentionally come on will
say something shocking provocative or
nonsensical so they can get a drama clip
to make money and let me just stress the
majority report has like 170 clips about
about Dave Rubin okay Dave Rubin it has
his own channel and he talks but he is
like look we we have a bunch of clips
about Biden and Hunter and Trump David
Pacman has a bunch of clips about these
people okay I get it we're talking
politics here we're gonna talk about
world leaders but Dave Rubin why are you
making clips about David why making
clips about me world leaders baby
they're not it's not it's because it
gets it gets raging it's rage bait it's
e-drum it's internet blood Sports so
this is why I'm like I normally don't
invite people like this on the show
because I know that all they're going to
do is come on and they're going to say
things with the intent to get a viral
clip well know that that's going to
happen it's called reactive abuse and
psychology so if someone does try to
trigger you or work you up in a
conversation stay calm oh yeah but I
don't care like you know the Benny knows
the thing where she got where she was
like I'm sorry I triggered you was
because she did the she literally said
why do you think your show appeals to
neo-nazis oh yeah I have an answer for
that because I think people that might
be radicalized into becoming a Neo-Nazi
in their lifetime will see shows like
this and become de-radicalized because
but but the point is the show doesn't in
fact we get threats from neo-nazis and
even staunch conservatives are very
critical of us it was the the goal of it
was to get a viral clip on the internet
that didn't it didn't matter what I said
to her it did it didn't matter if I
responded at all all that matters I get
a clip of her saying it and splice
together with something else and then
make a fake segment for their show
because that's what their show is drama
grifting garbage and how aggravated you
got when she accused you by the way of
inspiring a violent terror attack which
you should be angry about like well but
somebody tries to put that on my point
is it didn't matter if I got aggravated
or said nothing at all no matter what I
do no matter what I did they would take
that clip and then splice it with
something else and so we then bring up
the point there was there was one guy
who was posting stuff who had had
watched the majority report uh you
mentioned the guy Gavin long who said he
was inspired by The Young Turks and then
she teaches me was like I don't know I
don't know I don't know and she didn't
respond to it because the goal here's my
assumption Sam said specifically ask
this question it doesn't matter what
they say afterwards we need this clip
for our show because it'll trick a bunch
of morons into watching right I don't
think he said that specifically that's
what his intent is so afterwards when
Sean then brings up a legitimate point
of how could you say that when you have
say The Young Turks where you used to
work was the actual inspiration for a
guy who claimed it was and she goes I
don't know I don't know I don't know she
didn't respond in any capacity because
they're it wouldn't do anything for
their clip they she said the thing it's
on camera they can make the clip
anything after that is pointless
so so now it's like she's just literally
like I'm done with the conversation I
came here I got what I what I came for
you know yeah okay it's grifting garbage
and so I even said that I was like this
is why people you know Sam Cedar's
blacklisted from a whole bunch of shows
and Cedar baby he's blacklisted he knows
he is and I loved that she goes it's
because they're scared of him it's like
oh shut up actually because it's Destiny
did say if there was any liberal or
anyone on the left he was afraid to
debate it would be Sam Cedar he he Sam
is notoriously he's a brilliant man
whether or not you like him personally
is almost Irrelevant in that in that
capacity I think it's just e-drama
nonsense and then he makes videos about
Dave Rubin and me and other YouTubers
because it's just you've got people on
YouTube and you want to get clicks so
you target the community that they're in
they're a part of which is YouTube
so we we we're we're a podcast we're on
all different podcast platforms she made
she made comments about how we they
can't get the corporate investors like
we do and I'm like what like we don't
have any corporate investors she goes we
can't get sponsors like you doing I'm
like what we haven't we currently have
no sponsors none of the podcast I think
we have like four like what are you
talking about it like it's they're
they're saying things that are Plum not
true because they're lying to their
audience and Their audience just
believes it it's just it's low tier
internet drama garbage
I like to extricate that from people's
careers and and kind of refine the
process to have more elucidated
educational conversation
says when Emma accused you and asked why
Nazis watch your show to clarify the
context it was a guy who posted four
screenshots was it screenshots
screenshots from like the YouTube of the
same video of the same video he wasn't
subscribed to the channel and then she
said he posted clips from the show I
said no he didn't it was screenshots and
to be so she didn't even know what she
was talking about it was actually two
because they're like the same time code
more or less like a second off so it's
like something I do when I'm looking
when I see something and I want to
respond to it screenshot the app and
like you save that time code so you can
go back and revisit it what if the Nazis
could have won World War II by taking
pictures of Americans and putting them
on their walls at home oh they they took
they were watching us therefore we must
what what does that have anything who
cares about digress T-Rex says when Emma
accused you and asked why Nazis watch
your show in the culture War all her
future arguments weren't taken seriously
in my mind that was the stupidest
argument ever her reputation is now
ruined support anti-woke Pro Freedom
T-Rex Pet Shop the point is she did not
come here to have a real conversation in
fact before the show started I said is
there a subject you guys would like to
start with and she says I'm trying to
talk about whatever and then I said I
was under the impression that Sean and I
mean you guys want to talk about crime
we can talk about uh Jordan Williams I
believe and then Sean said yes and then
Emma said yes and then as soon we
started the show she immediately started
talking about Sam and music videos and
just the personal social compound like
I'm in your compound so you have money
like she was like I am hearing your
compound you have money I'm like yeah
it's all members like we have we have we
got rid of all our sponsors we only had
four now we only have on the podcast
side of thing like four or five and all
of the right revenue is basically
programmatic but primarily members and
then she said something about like us
having Rumble money or something she's
disappointed she didn't see this game it
was like Rumble has investors or
something like that therefore you have
Rumble investors like like gave me an
award for having subscribers just like
YouTube did the other funny thing they
like to do is they have to they have to
claim that tons of people live here they
don't this is an office with a skate
park in it and try to make it seem like
it's creepy and culty or I guess Sam was
implying we have children here or
something like that in the basement oh
my God what I don't know exactly are you
people are you keeping them comfortable
saying something like who are these kids
he's bringing to come skate how are they
but I I don't watch it this is just what
I was told and so Cedar but they have to
do it because the reality of it is we
have a building that has one two
let's see one two three
four five five floors uh uh so there's a
basement and a sub basement sub basement
is a skate park in it and then there's
uh three above ground floors and
actually split into two different above
ground sections and uh on ten acres plus
the construction of Freedom if you were
to go to someone and they say where do
you work like I work at a recording
studio it's got a music studio it's got
two podcast Studios we have rock stars
coming and going presidential candidates
and there's two skate parks inside
people will be like that sounds like the
best workplace ever yeah there's a bunch
of food there there's there's booze you
know within reason people drink when we
know when they feel like it you can hang
out downstairs and play pool or just go
to the skate park skate park outside
fresh fruit all over the trees such as
sauna on the premises as well and and
there was a hot tub for a minute
that they have to tarnish because it's
like uh oh we can't we can't let people
think that something cool is actually
possible or happening here so then they
try and do things where they send these
shows that like it's a bunch of guys
living in a weird house what a creepy
cult it's like no that's not that's not
true no it's a company if there was no
company and you were just like hey guys
come hang out at my house then it would
be a weird cult but it's like a company
where people accept Escape skateboarders
literally do that famously I think
America had the skate Mansion where all
their all their pros and amps lived in
one big house in California like that's
literally what they did razors used to
have that in skating as well yeah it's
like a thing that these companies do but
we should we should definitely real
quick even if it were true that you had
like all the people living here which
I've looked around I didn't find anybody
hidden in the basement uh while you
weren't looking but they're content
creator houses are so normal in other
non-political like Realms like they
never criticized content like that's
like an actual thing in a business model
but that's that's the point like high
pass
like a half of tick tocks hype houses so
I'll tell you another thing they did uh
we were skating at Freedom Plaza in DC
and they got really really angry because
they couldn't muster up any kind of
cultural defense I said we're all gonna
go skate in DC everyone show up and they
started issuing threats they started
calling companies threatening them if
they dared to associate with me in any
way it didn't work tons of people showed
up but I'm skating in uh uh uh the
Freedom Plaza and someone goes online on
a skate form a prominent one and says
Tim Poole was there and he couldn't do a
pop shove it pop shop is very very basic
trick that children do
why would they lie about that because if
they went out and said Tim Poole rolled
up and did a Nolly 540 big spin first
try and he did a switch hard flip late
flip you know most you have no idea what
I'm saying but skateboarders would be
like damn I didn't know Tim was that
good at skateboarding and then all of a
sudden it's like uh oh we can't let this
guy have cultural influence
so I will shout out the barracks the
most prominent skate uh brand in the
world posted a clip of me doing a one
foot uh nollie 360. so my point is this
they're very very terrified of our
cultural Endeavors to the point where
they're desperately trying to make it
seem bad yes that's why the majority
report played Our Song you know in such
a way I'll describe that made it sound
really really bad and then said it
sounded really bad and then she comes on
the show and she's like we don't have
the technology to do that I'm like you
literally did it you played it through
like some speakers so it sounded like
garbage and then said the music was
garbage and look how bad it sounds to
trick your audience is what they do
anyway we should we should read super
chats instead of me just uh ranting
where we go um uh oh I'm gonna have to
read a lot more about it
David Toronto says Sean Strickland needs
to train Elon get him on the show by the
way the after show would be phenomenal
I'm 6'3 33 waist not huge at all and I
weigh 200 Elon is at least 230. agreed
yeah it says 198 on his profile
yeah six two 198. like I'm at the gayen
says that uh I'm gonna paraphrase
because I I think that's a bit too much
invective but I do want to appreciate
your Super Chat and read it he said
seeing Emma vigiland uh mouth off at
Sean about crime was
um was sad he said a lot more than that
uh he said it was like seeing a
disoriented baby first he'll arrogantly
charge Into The Swinging Arc Club
wielded by a Burly disgruntled drunken
Canadian first rapper
who haven't who hasn't had the comfort
of a woman or a hot meal in a year okay
so I read it anyway because it was good
but you know a little too much invective
yeah that's a good one write a
screenplay yeah thank you
the the thing uh that's really
interesting about these these
conversations with leftists is they
never know what my political positions
actually are
it's amazing right and so they're like
right-wing shows like this the funny
thing was in the beginning she claimed
this show had appealed to neo-nazis but
then later claimed that you were too
right-wing for our audience yeah your
moderate audience our moderate audience
and she claimed that the reason I say
that we have a moderate audience is to
try and trick people and I'm like the
people who are listening who view
themselves as moderates are being
tricked into thinking everyone else's
mouth
what is their argument I just don't
they're so scared they're so scared that
we're creating culture because culture
is intrinsically edgy artistic something
that pushes the limits and they are now
the establishment they are the ones
chilling for Forever War they're the
ones Shilling for the justice department
and the super State and the police state
they are the establishment and we are
actually the punk rockers and they can't
believe that we're the ones now running
Rolling Stone and like but there's a
belief that it's a competition like if
Tim cast wins majority report loses or
vice versa but the reality is we lift
each other up these conversations Emma
coming on this show earlier being here
we're all gaining from this this is oh
yeah this isn't twitch like we're
actually not competitors like because
we're both on YouTube but like twitch
you have to stream and all that but but
like uh we can grow in our own separate
areas and have crossover because you
know people can always come back and
watch the content all right Roman Nation
says Tim and Benny you are two you two
are the reason why I've started the Roma
rise of Middle America cast you're an
inspiration the truth and look forward
to chatting with you too soon right on
man appreciate the Super Chat space dude
based this is a podcast I will sub
Roma is it a YouTube channel or podcast
uh it just says Roma cast Roma r-o-m-a
okay uh let's see Jason Hutchison says
Tim you're explaining the Dunning Kruger
effect yes that's right when people are
too stupid to know they're stupid yeah
that page is Roman Nation by the way
rumination Roma Nation Raymond you
Stanley Jr says Emma kept trying to do
gotcha clips for her show not trying she
literally was it doesn't matter if she
actually gets us or not or me
particularly what matters is they
they're gonna edit it anyway like look
we put out a song
and you'd have to like it there's a lot
of songs that come out all the time by a
lot of people and most people don't like
any of those songs Taylor Swift may be
the most popular musician in the world
but I'm seven out of seven billion
people people I've imagined 95 of people
don't like her music that's okay you
make things for the people who like the
things so we made a song and then they
played it on their show in such a way
that it sounded really awful through
some kind of filter and then told Their
audience it sounds awful look how awful
it sounds it sounds like Nickelback
which it literally does not because
and that's a really good example of the
culture War too saying that our music
sounds like Nickelback it's because as I
think you were mentioning many
programmable people
Nickelback is a buzzword for uncool and
and you know it's a meme like Creed yeah
it's like you're a great bear you're not
allowed to like Nickelback no that's
basically if you're if you're on the
left and you like Nickelback they're
gonna laugh at you which is ridiculous I
think Nickelback had the best cover of
Devil Went Down to Georgia ever though
I'm not really a big fan of their music
what's about the one to the bottom of
everybody to the bottom of every battle
that was a billboard number one for like
six weeks but that was the point even
though our music sounds literally look
at this Photograph yeah that's like a
meme
a pre-federal Reserve Bank bill
sucks
we'll grab a couple more Super chats
Nickelback based I don't know but man
when you sing uh how you remind me and
you sing it like he's singing it and you
start to feel it it is based
he might have had the whole problem at
the time says totally disagree Tim your
goal for culture War shouldn't be to get
the sound clip of of talking about the
uh them showing kids graphic images the
win is two hours exposing her total
cognitive dissonance great job today I
appreciate it
um I think Destiny's fantastic uh you
guys know Destiny yes he he's we've had
him on several times we have real
conversations we have disagreements on
morality political structures but I know
that when he comes
he'll actually listen to the words
coming out of my mouth and then we'll
end up by saying like that's a good
point but I still disagree and he'll say
okay the same is true for conservatives
when I when I like I think I think I
also watched a clip of Destiny just
mouthing off at someone that was the
funniest stuff I I think he's great uh I
disagree with him a lot I think most
people who watch our show might just
probably disagree with them a lot but
probably actually like him a lot too
that that to me is a real conversation
that's the conversation I want to have I
would like to have Destiny be like
here's my position on surrogacy and then
sit down with a conservative who opposes
it and then we'll actually have a real
discussion on the issues we do that all
the time with Libertarians and
conservatives but it's so hard to find
liberals yes because they don't actually
have positions the crafts and States
come on here right they came on once the
crashing seeds come on here I thought
that was great yeah I thought so too I
interact with them a lot on Twitter and
I think getting getting banned fixed to
them
like it it helped them understand I
should say I don't want to be I don't I
don't think fix them is is is is is uh
rude I apologize for that I think that
they understood finally when they were
wrongly banned what was going on and
then came out of it like maybe we should
have paid attention a little bit because
that was an unjust Banning and now I
disagree with them a lot in their
positions but it genuinely seems like
they'll actually engage with you in an
honest way so I believe that the
beginning of everyone's journey to
actual real knowledge politically is
being able to criticize your own side
that's how you can tell if you were
talking with a cult member or somebody
who's actually a rational human being
who's on their way to Namaste right if
you're able to criticize your own son
you could you should listen to the
Johnson household Kate and I are doing
nothing but talking s on Republicans I
republi I hate Republicans so much more
than Democrats because Republicans uh
Democrats at least the goodness and
kindness in their hearts to stab me in
the face they tell me exactly where
they're gonna stab me and how they're
gonna do it Republicans stab me in the
back and so I am so much angrier at
Republicans than Democrats on a daily
basis all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends become a
member at timcast.com buy your coffee
from castbrew.com K-Cups are on their
way I'm really excited for this the
decaf Brews all of it's coming in and I
just want to stress this we have not
made any money yet so uh we would
appreciate it if you would buy our
product so uh what I should say is we
have sold a lot it has been profitable
but we've had to put all of that money
plus more into doing more
I think we're upwards of like 300 or
400k in the first four roasts then
K-Cups and all that initial investment
is massive and then you guys buy it and
then the product goes down we make
profit and then we reuse that profit to
add more products so it's the all the
investment cycle so it's working uh
we're really excited for it things are
are expanding and we really do
appreciate all of your support uh you
can follow the you can follow the show
at uh timcastiro basically everywhere
you can follow me at timcast Benny do
you want to shout anything up yeah you
can uh go ahead and join million a
million people can't be wrong you can
join our YouTube channel and might as
well just toss it out there I've been
following along in the comment section I
see some names that I recognize from our
show we just want to say thank you we've
done a million Subs in less than one
year of actually cranking on content and
we've decided to really like invest in
that community and so we're proud of it
we love you we thank you we love coming
back here and doing the show I think
this is my fourth time on pimcast and we
thank uh Tim and this this audience
because because coming on this show
really helps boost your audience if you
have something good to offer and you
really like dedicate your time and do
the hard work and don't just assume that
an audience just comes for free you have
to work and grind sleepless nights and
weekends and everything but we are here
for you and we just want to say thank
you we love you
I'm at actual Justice Warrior on YouTube
don't have a million subscribers yet but
you know you guys could fix that tonight
just you know go on and subscribe I
really appreciate my gold play button uh
I have a website actual Justice
warrior.com you can find all my links
right there
uh guys if you want to follow me it's at
Brett dasovic on Instagram and Twitter
and pop culture crisis is live Monday
through Friday 3 P.M Eastern Standard
Time that is noon Pacific we had a great
episode today with Heather and Derek
Hunter it was really really good you
should go and check that out I'm Ian
cross and I will be live tonight with
Elijah Shaffer on slightly offensive on
YouTube we will be going live in about
15 minutes 10 15 Eastern Standard time
it is coming up so get ready to click
over join slightly offensive on YouTube
also on Rumble I'm gonna be happy to see
Elijah my man Benny nice always great
dude Sean excellent to see you my man
Tim welcome back Brett and serge du Prez
Elijah still in Australia I think so
yeah I guess that's 11 o'clock he starts
to stream at like 11 p.m Eastern
Standard Time he's doing a favor for me
because I had the show tonight so he
might be staying up a little later than
normal but we'll find out when we go
live on slightly offensive
yeah Elijah dude I talked to him on
Twitter quite a lot but yeah anyways
good show pleasure to see you Benny and
pleasure to be acquainted with you I
should say rather I've seen you on
YouTube a couple times so yeah anyways
uh good show guys search.com on Twitter
see you later thanks for hanging out
everybody I apologize for being out all
week except for today but uh got my
voice back should be back perfectly on
Monday and we'll see y'all then